peu
[Musique]
au nom de quoi tu me parles de quoi la
radio ou à la télé les journaux tout le
monde enfin à le truc mais oui ce matin
chez lo presti m'attend mais tout aussi
fait l'impasse sûr que tout le monde
samedi soir
bienvenue sur la plateau de tout le
monde en parle
vous connaissez le principe tout le
monde entend alors tout le monde en
parle
et voilà merci je me demande de vous
arrêter
quand j'ai eu beaucoup du mail beaucoup
beaucoup d'e-mails encore cette semaine
et la plupart parlent de mareva galanter
n'en parlera tout à l'heure et le cadet
olivier vous voulez savoir quand ils
reviennent ils sont là
[Applaudissements]
jusqu'ici
bien les oliviers alors ça fait une paye
qu'on s'est pas vu ça ça va
alors ça fait une paye qu'on s'est pas
vu mais simplement bravo canada serge
lama brammo à la salicaire pense que
mickaël que ce soir est pas sûr de
conserver son titre de champion du monde
de blind test bien alors on va on vous
retrouve quand même cette année comme
l'année dernière tous les jours sur
comédie le 19 à 20 heures et de 18 à 19
heures fête l'autoroute de la fortune
sur europe 2 oui et en attendant on est
très heureux t
mais non pas dans ma
bon allez devoir et samson bravo les
compagnons de la chanson
et l'or alors à mikhail intérêt à bien
se donner un équipé que thierry c'est
qu'ils me veulent mais michael c'est le
mec à gagner chaque semaine depuis le
début de la saison trois semaines de
suite
il tentera de devenir vraiment star le
mec rambouillet ce soir et ce soir il a
un petit peu peur d'avoir peur il a un
petit peu mais elle est bête
y'a pus linda hardy jamais eu de réponse
vous la force de mon doigt par ap visage
par kad et olivier je recevrai ce soir
massimo gardien
la croupe sandrine kiberlain
frédéric bellay
jean luc bennahmias
bernard violet pour sa bio n'autoriser
d'alain delon et 6,9
mais non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vraiment y avoir du sport ce soir alors
j'ai eu pas mal de 10 miles domptin d'un
dénommé grego alors lui il a un truc
l'huile un truc très marrant grego il me
pose une question évidemment je peux pas
répondre à la télé donc je vais faire
juste un geste tu vas comprendre voilà
ah oui si tu veux des maracas
ouais c'est ça vient on s'est dit ça n'a
pas changé et truc ont pas changé dans
l'évolution de chaque album c'est le
meilleur public de paris saclay
maintenant non seulement il fait ça le
public non plus et pose des questions
aux invités non si faut pas faire ça ici
et alors un truc a pas changé c'est que
chaque semaine on voit les meilleurs
moments de la semaine précédente
voilà qui s'appelle tout le monde en a
parlé
vous êtes à paris parce qu'à votre 77e
disque qui sort en soixante dix etienne
c'est vrai obligé de le dire je ne fais
pas et chaque année c'est le jour de
votre anniversaire et voilà votre cadeau
je vous avais pas dit ça m'arrive à vous
ça c'est le cadeau de julio aparicio si
vous cachez pas votre petite amie vous
êtes la première à dire oui je me tue
tamis s'appelle pascal etc
au moins tout va bien les gens croient
que miss france et vierge
moi je pensais ça
ah bah oui j'étais persuadé que linda
hardy était vierge thermique la france
c'est une histoire très sexuée daniel à
la relève alors toi tu les prends tu
continues tu sais quand tu descends de
paix quand ils descendent trop petit le
monde
je passe tout le pari est le manager
j'arrive à la démission françaises ont
passé au moins ne reçoivent aucune
chanson ici à la télévision ce qu'ils
aient été des dédicaces ou pas je vais
te faire après comment comment il fait
mareva est ce que vous êtes maso ou est
ce que vous aimez quand on vous fait mal
ça dépend des jours et comment ça dépend
où et comment mais vous n'êtes pas
contre le principe je les adore cette
manne vous aimez les cassettes pornos
vous regardez des films et oui mais
quand vous dormez tout seul chez vous le
soir vous avez pas peur je m'enferme à
ses chiens
c'est pas pratique pour vous est
incroyablement sexy francis huster
comment est-ce que vous résister aux
sollicitations féminin je pense à
christiane ah ouais c'est la chance de
ma vie
on a montré face à cristiano c'est bien
je suis moche je suis mal foutu j'ai des
jambes maigres
vous avez des gens de make way mareva ça
c'est pas la jambe
[Applaudissements]
c'était tout
on a parlé le best-of de la semaine
dernière alors comme je vous le disais
beaucoup beaucoup de d'e-mails
concernant mareva galanter
il ya un garçon qui s'appelle sinico de
ce plat nicolas mon avis et qui dit pour
mareva je veux bien m'appeler pascal est
allé habiter à paris il ya guillaume qui
est appelé sous sa golf galanter jeu
mais qu'il est tellement amoureux de
marie la paix sans char rodolphe
galanter ya laurent qui voudraient
savoir s'il pourrait rencontrer la soeur
de mareva galanter et cela encore plus
loin puisque ana qui dit qui était la
fille qui était derrière mareva galanter
le haut violet les cheveux tirés voilà
il dit je suis fou de ses yeux c'est ça
a déclenché cette émission
nous on va avoir des idées ça vous aurez
des emails bien-aller déjà beaucoup qui
vous réclamez olivier août à paris ça y
est maintenant c'est devenu ici en fait
on fait semblant mais c'est cool
maintenant on va voir ce que vous faites
sur comédie d'accord avec sursis ok
qu'est ce que vous avez comme indice
rires j'ai interrogé gerald turner le
garagiste
c'est lui qui a découvert le corps on
est à l'avant c'est pas lui
ou qu'est ce qui vous fait croire ça il
a juré j'aurais et craché il a juré
craché
vous avez conservé son clavier oui il a
dans ce gobelet posé sur le bureau et
moi j'ai un doute qui m'assaillent
depuis ce matin oui je vous écoute j'ai
pas d'enfant non aucun alors c'est le
concierge qui viennent à l'école
vous êtes bien sur le répondeur de linda
hardy
je ne suis pas là pour le moment mais
vous pouvez me laisser un message
après le bip sonore au revoir non rien
jacques qu'est ce que c'est que ce
paquet je sais pas c'était mon pantalon
qui est un peu fermé vous avez vu reaper
dehors même la nuit
les gens vivent mal impression qu'ils
refusent arrêter de vivre c'est beau la
nuit une ville
même les enfants sont debout à cette
heure encore valides oui vous avez
gardez vos lunettes de soleil il est 10
heures du matin assez marrant ça fait
peur quand vous moucher avec vos doigts
comme ça me rappelait mon ancien
équipier stéphane beurre dieu ait son
âme
il est mort près
une overdose russe héroïne non françois
fellmann excusez moi je ne savais pas
vous ne pouviez pas savoir
de montrichard d'olic et du blaster
tenteront de répondre à la question que
tout le monde se pose qui a tué pamela
rose dans la grosse émission
là
à
je me demande de vous arrêter sur bien
alors il ya un email d'un type qui
s'appelle john mccain qui est belge qui
ont évidemment regardé par beaucoup de
belges est la meilleure preuve qu'il est
belge c'est qu'il dit pourquoi serge
khalfon il dit toujours ça en est moche
pas pendant le dîner gala donc il est
vraiment belle alors je vous parle je
veux faire une interview spéciale pour
vous qui s'appelle l'interview sans
intérêt ça c'est cool on ne bouge pas
pendant le génial
vous savez bien bouger mois on n'a pas
bougé serge bon il me espion à une
question chacun dans l'interview sans
intérêt on commence avec vous cad est ce
que vous savez coudre intéressant voyez
avec les pieds seulement bien olivier
vous préférez la mer ou la montagne
difficile comme question pour le temps
de répondre la montagne la montagne
cannes est ce qu'elle vous a rappelé qu'
est-ce que vous aimiez les cols
difficiles qu'ont question la montagne à
la montagne mais est ce que qu'a dit ce
que vous avez dit balle pour le kabyle
n'a pas vraiment faux julien si je dis
bah ouais c'est l'un des buts sans
intérêt pas vider mes poches parce que
sinon vous allez avoir des petites
surprises format 100 g sur moi donc on
n'est pas chez comédie chez paddy balle
vous avez pas dit balle pour lequel vous
avez vu les résultats du référendum
c'est incroyable
oh la la c'est l'interview sans intérêt
évidemment
vous avez fermé voiture je n'ai pas de
voiture
c'est très bonne règle et c'est des
trucs en même temps je teste cannes vous
y croyez à ce truc vous car les oliviers
sans jacquet
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
elle est dans sa loge ivana trump
l'abattoir ivana trump la femme de l'ex
femme de donald trump
en attendant voici un ami d'ivana trump
voici le pape de la jet set
massimo gargia
bien sûr
qui
ainsi moment soit au carrelet en ligne
et massimo gargia vers gaza à la voile
intégral la politique n'est pas la
politique à l'égard des bains parce que
justine henin
c'est pour ça alors ça va massimo très
bien alors dites-moi massimo vous aviez
15 kilos à perdre cet été vous avez
perdu
non on compterait gp un collègue ça fait
vingt à perdre pour l'été prochain
terrible terrible alors vous êtes chalet
nasa quoi à chacun sa croix bien sûr
j'ai kad et olivier
est ce que vous êtes vous êtes est ce
qu'on peut dire que vous êtes le boute
en train des riches
un peu le le chef du protocole de la jet
set
on m'appelle aussi l'homme de tous les
bonheurs assez jolis seins l'homme de
tous les bonheurs les riches ils ont
beaucoup d'argent ils savent pas comment
le dépenser et massimo vous êtes fait
partie des gens qui les aider à dépenser
oui à s'amuser
j'ai tout dépensé tout ma vie je dépeins
savander gagnable
et alors vous organiser des événements à
commencer par deux best parce que debès
c'est d'abord un magazine et puis c'est
aussi un événement chaque année c'est
une cérémonie
vous remettez les best aux gens les plus
élégants c'est ça oui je vais donner à
lui
les gars tu pourrais avoir un best alors
on va raconter un petit peu la vie de
massimo gargia qui a une vie très très
étonnant que ce soit on a d'ailleurs
beaucoup de beaucoup de destin étonnant
avec vous avec ivana trump avec c'est
vraiment des gens qui ont des destins
incroyables vous étiez un jeune
napolitain désargenté au départ 1 et
puis vous avez passé votre vie en fait à
mener une vie de milliardaire de la jet
set donc c'est plutôt bien réussie vous
êtes content résultats alors vous dites
finalement cette vie si c'est pas le
bonheur c'est l'illusion du bonheur en
moins oui tiens vous avez le sentiment
de vivre dans une espèce de bulle de
champagne toute votre vie comme ça mais
il s'est déjà beaucoup à voile et
l'audio ou bien sûr vous publiez un
livre vous publiez un certain james l
à vous ne faites pas maxime aussi moins
six mois
s'appelle jet set dans toutes les
mémoires d'un playboy international chez
michel lafon et c'est massimo gargia et
c'est un livre très très étonnant moi je
les lui au départ bon je croyais que
c'était très superficielle que c'était
très léger frivole et en fait c'est vrai
c'est sincère et c'est très étonnant à
cause de sa préface de françoise sagan
françoise sagan est une amie on peut
dire que massimo en rester là pour le
moment et ça pourrait être très content
bouquins et c'est génial et d'ailleurs
je suis pas le seul à avoir dit parce
qu'il ya des critiques littéraires en
france qui ont reconnu que c'était autre
chose qu'une compilation de souvenirs de
jet setteur on va vous raconter bombe à
la jet set au début ça s'appelait la
café society et des familles de la haute
société internationale et puis petit à
petit a eu des grosses familles
industrielles comme les acnés lille
justement l est et rothschild et puis
quand grace kelly est arrivé à monaco
finalement ça a été le début des acteurs
dans la jet set le début des couturiers
dans la jet set et ça a commencé à
vraiment changé à ce moment là quoi
s'ouvrir un peu oui à s'ouvrir au monde
de la mode parce qu'à l'époque
n'existait pas et les salves sont
devenues les mannequins des modèles et
les côtoyer aussi sont devenus très
importants à l'ebit ajouté aussi et puis
d'un seul coup quand même maintenant
c'est devenu très très mercantile la jet
set non non j'ai pas qu'ils essaient par
un bijoutier grand mot tout ça change
dans les noms et les visages du monde a
changé
c'est naturel que même la modalité
changer alors massimo gargia donc aînés
en ont peut le dire qu'elle est pas vous
étonner si sa nécessaire donc vous êtes
rentré dans la jet set en 1965 à l'âge
de 24 ans comme ça on sait que
comme les gens de l'importance à la ils
sont où c'est vrai que la calculette est
terrible c'est le calcul mental d'un
régionaux ritalin cd puis passera à côté
de chaque personnage on me lajoie et
rible mission de selouane alors donc
vous êtes rentré d'un jet set en fait
grâce à pierre cardin nous connaissent
et pierre cardin oui bien sûr les
garages faire garder la garde
et alors tout de suite j'ai été très
très beau vraiment magnifique
c'est pas vous êtes mal maintenant mais
franchement j'étais craquant et alors
tout de suite une femme vous prend sous
son aile
j'ai dit comme ça
une dame de 60 ans qui s'appelait cécile
de rothschild ça a été la première
finalement la soeur du baron guy de
rothschild qui s'est occupé de vous quoi
hein
et vous dites dans votre bouquin vous
dit j'étais jeune et vigoureux et ja
devrait séduire
il fait très vigoureux massivement et
alors vous dites j'aime efforcé de ne
pas me muer en simple gigolo pourquoi
parce que vous savez si vous comparez
c'est dans une scène de la société et
et vous arrivez comme gigolo vous est
marqué à vie alors c'est pas mal quand
on a 24 ans et qu'on sort avec une femme
riche de 60 ans c'est difficile de pas
être taxé ji gaullisme non merci
oui mais en effet beaucoup des gens au
début on passait saad et moi mais j'ai
démontré après que c'était pas vrai vous
dites j'ai accepté ses cadeaux mais j'ai
forcé de ne pas me faire entretenir
oui j'ai eu tellement des succès avec
les personnes les plus âgées pose
plusieurs personnes je n'ai pas dit
d'aller livre je voulais pas blessés qui
sont essayés décider pour moi j'avais
beaucoup de succès et mes fils et des
cadeaux extraordinaires et moi je dois
dire la vérité j'adorais les cadeaux
vous rigolez mais il n'est jamais arrivé
alors massimo la question important de
six mois à l'époque j'étais un playboy
[Musique]
alors gigolo playboy du préfet plus
proche playboy d'accord alors cécile de
rothschild on continue parce que c'est
que le début cécile de rothschild je
vous présente une amie à elle sa
meilleure amie greta garbo et attend les
mobylettes vous vous y allez langage
pierre cardin way sens bien celle-là au
greta garbo donc avait 64 ans et vous 25
mai 1 et alors à l'époque on était dans
une phase de greta garbo de réclusion
extrême non elle et elle sortait plus du
tout elle se montrait plus et vous les
plus obtus et moi j'essayais dès la
sortie de la récession dès tout ça mais
on vous dit en parlant greta garbo à
l'époque elle était d'une beauté
renversante un visage de presque
enfantin malgré ses 64 ans quand
d'intérêt dans une chambre immédiatement
il avait la façon dans laquelle marché
même si c'était pas en femme d'une
beauté ces années quelque chose j'ai
donc pensé à elle
si l entrée dans une chambre s'est tout
de suite hein
c'est marrant alors vous dites
d'ailleurs un truc c'est que greta garbo
préférer la compagnie des femmes 1 d'une
façon générale elle préfère accompagner
les femmes aussi bien sur le plan social
que sexuel tyrrell elle mais bien les
femmes
d'une façon générale mais j'ai
l'impression qu'elle n'était pas fort
physiquement des mois et demi et ferrer
ma compagnie comme will accompagner tout
ça allait mais en fait que voulait ce
quartier voilà mais parce qu'elle était
une femme très seule et ça m'avait
beaucoup avec moi et moi je lis palais
jamai du cinéma a détesté par les gens
salariale et de sacs allait passer et
c'était une femme qui n'avait pas les
systèmes nerveux pour supporter tout la
célébrité qu'elle était tombée sur les
épaules
alors bon c'est très dur vous complétez
patrelle préférer les filles le
triolisme ci avec le groupe ce qui est
nous arrêter là parce que je commence à
être un peu
citez moi j'ai mon collègue grâce à luc
oursel dans le bouquin oui ça va nous
chauffer la scène dans le bouquin de
massimo où il dit ben voilà son honneur
de playboy est en jeu quoi il dit à un
moment il faut y aller il me fallait il
me fallait posséder la star la plus
célèbre du monde
parce qu'à mon époque c'était une autre
sortie avec une femme est pas couché
avec moi pas pourquoi aujourd'hui c'est
fini ça c'est l'inversé fini maintenant
c'est fini
à l'époque oui allez donc machine où il
va dans le noir ça s'est passé dans le
noir avec la tagab s'est elle voulait
noir absolu se trouve ce n'était pas
grave car vous vous dites j'ai dû même
inspiré la porte avec jérémy une
serviette on bat pour qu'ils passent que
la finale est d'accord et alors
le lendemain vous la trouvez très froide
en fait un avec rielle voulait pas pas
l'aider ce n'est pas pareil ça ne
voulait pas épiloguer comme un non dit
certains et alors en fait vous dit-elle
pratiquer le sexe avec moi uniquement
pour me faire plaisir oui c'est pas elle
n'est pas passionné ouais alors bon bah
salon votre carrière et puis alors il ya
un épisode évidemment fameux sais qu'un
jour vous avez des amis paradis et vous
organiser une séance
voilà vous arrivez l'aéroport de milan y
est au complet en gav sens qui viennent
dé naples et qui sort avec la femme la
plus célèbre du monde
c'est terrible pour un playboy alors
j'ai pas résisté à la fin j'ai pas les
east et un ami à moi m'a dit je t'aime
moi en photographie sont arrivés trois
photographes et voilà et elle m'a dit
elle m'a dit
en anglais la tourmente je le dis aux
français tous douma trip to my hood fois
tout n'aura jamais plus voilà oui ça a
été fini ça a été fini pour toujours une
époque parce qu'à l'époque vous aviez
grace kelly aujourd'hui philippe kelly
devrait vous sortiez classiche est un
fidèle au six mois
ils ont été maintenus pour connais bien
arte va diffuser nos questions alors
après on faisait une aventure avec
françoise sagan qui a une phrase qui
était marié à l'époque été marié qu'à
l'américain oui
après ça continuait toujours là au bout
des débats à une à quelques-unes et
encore maintenant c'est une amitié
amoureuse est alors françoise sagan elle
dit en parlant parce qu'ils étaient
mariés à l'époque a dit en parlant de
son mari la trahison est le seul moyen
d'assurer la survie d'un mariage la
raison je suis tout à fait 2 est marié
mais c'est quand même dingue mais dans
beaucoup de liberté très intelligent
mais beaucoup de liberté
d'autres d'autres aventures ailleurs
tout ça non parce que quand vous dont la
liberté vous n'avez plus un b les gens
qui sont allés mais voilà chaque semaine
on essaie ici de savoir comment se
démerder l'affiché lui il dit cécile
afin de lui expliquer que la fidélité
c'était dans la tête la tête et alors
j'adore michel sagan elle vous apporter
en plus une touche culturelle pour vous
c'était vachement bien parce que quand
même bon de rester là 10 pour les autres
mais les garder avec elle à jamais parlé
dès l'été à tous avec moi ça n'est ce
pas le préfet palais avec bemba frein
alors et là alors on arrive aux choses
importantes pelham messieurs
et moi je préfère les rousses de 83 ans
chantait yann et les abeilles
parce que massimo à 31 ans vous
découvrez que vous n'avez jamais
travaillé vous refusé d'épouser une
riche héritière
non en effet je détestais l'idée du
mariage tout au fond il ya en vérité que
j'étais appelé baril n'est pas ce que
j'ai toujours détesté les mariages
l'idée d'être prisonnier de rentrée
toujours tous les soirs avec la même
femme
l'idée d'être obligé être là non j'ai
toujours détesté ça eh ouais mais si
vous arrêtez vous écouter les enfants
voilà j'aime bien pourquoi c'est vrai
c'est vrai hélas
julie lescaut l empire des armes heures
au pire en pire
lydia des terres ding alors je veux dire
qui c'est lydia les terres 10 je vous en
parlais beaucoup dans votre livre mais
en deux mots c'était là c'est elle
épouse d'un du comprimé gel la chaîne
voilà c'est ça c'était la femme de
monsieur chaînes thématiques petite
boutique donc monsieur shell était mort
le pauvre et donc elle avait 91 ans
était là elle en chasse de chair fraîche
et alors ça commence très fort pour
avoir dansé sauvagement avec cette dame
lydia massimo obtient une montre en or
quartiers là messieurs concussion vos
papilles qu'elle ait connue depuis les
soirs que j'ai connu pendant un mois
oui tous les jours ma moyens que
d'autres mesures partout j'étais n'ont
pas tellement changé ou la chaleur des
montres des choses d'un tableau ou pas
tout j'étais si j'étais passé avant même
envoyé ça c'était l'époque où massimo
flirter avec les dyades et erding pour
le trajet oui un petit peu ou quoi avez
vous savez ce qui a eu pour pour le plus
quoi pour le plus mal c'est énormément
rue de la faisanderie dans le césium
oui mais d'abord faut le faire et là
vous avez peur pas y arriver là vous
vous dites à un moment mais vous avez
une réaction art pepper louise une
réaction d'ailleurs vous dites bon les
sexagénaires est majoritaire dont elle
avait 80 un peu plus de 80 ans
voilà alors ce qu'il faut venir des
enfants attendez attendez si vous voulez
un drapeau l'appartement rue de la
faisanderie alors c'est plus que de la
faisons pas j'ai pas osé et alors non
qu'est-ce-qui massimo à ce moment là
même si vous ne deviez se dit bon les
sexagénaires que ce soit à cécile de
rothschild ou greta garbo elle avait 60
ans et 60 ans y'a pas de problème
et là c'est 80 mes enfants et qu'est-ce
qui fait massimo qu'est-ce qui fait il
boit un petit coup de champagne pour se
redonner un botté de coups de bouteille
et alors tories arrivés ouais et leur
page 137 je signe à la page 130 mal
parce que je la connaissais pas bien
après et je vais dire j'étais plus
jamais surpris par son châssis vote
était beau
non non non parce que dans les livres
jeudi après que la fin j'étais conquis
par l etat c'est ce que vous dites vous
dites bon effectivement aussi l
intérieur l avaient pas fait l'amour
depuis longtemps donc dit massimo il me
semble à pénétrer une jeune vierge c'est
ça c'est le cinéma qui se bat il avait
intéressés la libye mais il dit il
ajoute une une vierge experte en joute
sexuelle c'est là vous a été très
surpris par apa finalement par l'énergie
au lit de de lydiane et erding qui avait
dans tous les bons coups mais moi oui
c'est vrai c'est vrai que masimo a
toujours été très aidé par les femmes et
et vous dites c'est un pied de nez et
c'est après oui oui raconter l'histoire
de nina après mais c'est très très mal
terminé et alors donc voilà le lendemain
vous êtes chez le notaire et vous avez
votre appartement rue de la faisanderie
la forme il faut qu'il faut le savoir le
faire surtout plus maximo et c'est un
charmant même jour d'ailleurs et voilà
et alors là vous commencez quand même à
être un peu victime faut dire la vérité
dans le milieu pour fréquenter un peu
victime de moqueries de strass isme de
la part des gens parce que aujourd'hui
s'appelle aucune impression en tout à
l'époque un certain choc dans les
milieux dans lesquels j'étais déjà dix
ans avec mes copines et camille monet
sur tous mes amis playboy qui monte tout
de suite et
mais tout doit la quitter si on te tout
ça c'était idiot de ma part parce qu'à
la fin après des ans j'ai suivi les
conseils d amis on doit jamais suivre
les conseils jamais voilà vous la voyez
encore aujourd'hui c'est un peu la
boulette mais hélas donc ça commence à
devenir chaud pour notre ami massimo
parce que bien en mai y aller mais
commence à parler de mariage
alors même si mon oeil ou là là là quand
même 25 ans elle 83 ans qui se dit non
vous n'êtes pas mariée est là alors rien
il ya un truc mais ce livre il faut
absolument le lire là je le montre à la
caméra parce qu'il ya un moment
extraordinaire c'est que massimo et dans
l'intimité avec lydiane et erding et
elle lui dit je vous montrer une photo
et à louvres un petit ami chip cox comme
ça il ya lui montre une photo et ce qui
est extraordinaire c'est que son mari le
fondateur de la chaîne avant la guerre
avait rendu visite à hitler dans le nid
d'aigle ont été décrits des livres sur
l'amitié de son mari est très voilà et
c'est un mariage elle conteste pas de
cette dame pardon j'étais tendu j'étais
allé voir ils tuèrent et donc il avait
passé un déjeuner à 1 personne gadon
avec hitler eva braun libyan et erding
et son mari mais et après le déjeuner et
était devenue la maîtresse du tiers et
là vous vous retrouvez devant elle dit
au père vous dit au passage qu'elle vous
avouer qu hitler était pratiquement un
puissant un bon ce qui explique que pas
mal de choses
ce qui explique pas mal de choses il l'a
là vous êtes bouleversé vous vous dites
je tiens dans mes bras et m'a dit si les
dames hier mois d'aidé en clamant ont
été persécutés par les fascistes à
l'italie je suis né une famille
socialiste et tout ça
deux oncles à moins ont été tuées par
les fascistes en italie et alors je
mange avait un choc entre m sam est
bloquée même sexuellement après je sais
qu'il ya c'est que la grèce ait couché
avec sinon y'a pas de problème
et alors là vous êtes bon elle elle vous
elle veut toujours rester avec vous elle
vous propose de vous monter une affaire
de décoration vous revoyez sagan à ce
moment-là et lydia détruit entièrement
la décoration entièrement salon les
examens et elle détruit entièrement et
alors
donc elle détruit la décoration
d'appartements qui avait avait coûté une
fortune il y avait des tableaux de gally
tout sale détruit tout tout tout jusqu
aux ampoules à led jour et l'arachide ou
il des ampoules dans deux jours en deux
jours dans deux joueurs et après j'ai
découvert ce qu'andré décorateurs les
architectes masqué on a besoin dans six
mois pour des raisons c'est pas vrai
parce qu'après pour l'art et oies j'ai
demandé qu'elle aimait la maison comme
elle était avant l arrêt fait dans
quinze jours voilà massimo lui a dit à m
simon lui dit ah bon ils se réconcilient
lui dit mais l'appartement t'en fais pas
chérie deux jours après l'appartement
était de nouveau quand ils sont tous les
deux les toutes les ampoules tour
voilà je pourrais continuer comme ça
après tout celui qui a acheté le bouquin
c'est chez michel lafon s'est plaint
parce qu'après ça continue là je fais
juste un petit peu à la joindre à la
même pas la moitié
ac c'est une vie extraordinaire massimo
gargia
alors main sinon comme vous avez eu des
hauts et des bas dans votre vie un jeu
vous faire l'interview up and down
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je vous le dit massimo c'est la première
fois que oui je sais serge khalfon me
dis que j'ai bougé pendant le jingle je
vous le dis pour la suite de l'émission
ici on ne bouge pas tant le jingle il
faut pas s empêcher de bouger massive en
même temps c'est ce qui sauve les bouge
toujours bien ce que vous préférez dans
la jet set
belle et j'ai fait parce que la jet set
des foires vous trouvez vraiment des
grands amis qui vous sautent des
situations extraordinaires
vous préparez vous comprenez dans les
milieux disons qu'il n'est pas et
jet-set retours aidés grande amie
m'avait grande amie vous seulement des
mots de confort ouais
cependant si vous a trouvé en grande
amie de la jet set il peut vous changer
la vie dans les moments décisifs et vous
si vous faites sur qui est des prisons
plus très pragmatique easy tant qu'à
faire autant que les femmes autant
qu'elle soit riche tant qu'à avoir des
potes autant qu'ils soient en jet set
voilà en tout cas on est malheureux mais
trop non c'est ce qu'on appelle la
théorie de massimo gargia
qu'est ce que vous détestez dans la jet
set par les gens voulaient tester mais
en général qu'est ce que vous n'aimez
pas dans la jet set
la cruauté de la cruauté des foires et
deux fois quel est votre jet setteur
préféré sans discussion et 20 à 30
elle arrive elle arrive
celui que vous haïssez j'ai une idée non
ma présent plutôt vraiment laissé on
s'est fait chair mort avec 22 plaintes
oui à part emmanuel de brantes thierry
roland ne connais pas mais je n'ai pas
tiré vous connaissez pas dire violent
torturent et romain sinon quel est le
plus grand moment de votre vie
un beau moment de votre vie de toute
votre vie des plus beaux moments de ma
vie c'était quand j'ai vu l'un aussi que
j'étais capable de travailler j'avais du
succès la première soirée que
j'organisais pour gianni versace c'était
un triomphe et tout le monde m'a dit ça
ordinaire
c'était j'ai vu que j'étais
je pouvais commencer à travailler
autrement que comme les castors le pire
moment de votre vie
mais aller puis moment de ma vie c'était
qu'un sens être coupable j'étais accusé
d'avoir histoire marrakech oui c'est la
plus belle nuit de votre vie c'était la
première fois que j'arrivais à paris et
je suis allé un dîner où les thèmes et
taylor je suis arrivé il avait de l'or
partout et il y avait un arbre un or
dans les salles en sait on jamais au
kéké qui était très riche parce qu'il
était le roi de halle est en fait voilà
donc ça c'est la plus belle nuit la nuit
la plus moche tellement l'endroit où
vous rêveriez d'être en ce moment si
vous n'étiez pas avec nous au lieu
d'être sur un bateau sur le livre le
bateau d'ivana tralala mais est
l'endroit où vous détesteriez être ce
soir ce soir seul endroit où voudriez
vraiment pas être moi je n'aime pas sur
le bateau antoine
le bateau doit sinon qu'est ce qu'il ya
de plus qu'est ce qu'il ya de plus sexy
chez vous maintenant on peut pas dire et
de moins sexy la quête non je ne sais
pas je n'ai pas suffi non de moins sexy
mais sinon des moins sexy
de tout peut-être toujours le moment
très fort et il faut faire un régime là
massimo parce que ça vous obsède
dernière question ce que vous préférez
dans le sexe c'est que je préfère le
début du sexe les membres le flirt
le fleuve est ce que vous détestez dans
le sexe d'aller sexe c'est la haine
après quand vous quittez larmes quand on
change les serrures voilà ça car j'ai
compris merci dit massimo
notre nouvel ami
le gardien
j'accueille maintenant une amie de
massimo gargia la célèbre jet setteuse
ivana trump pas
la veille christophe you will love
tonight gelé pleasure la nation 50 ans
vous avoir auriez pu changer de robe
je traduis bien vous étiez donc marié on
va en parler avec donald trump le fameux
homme d'affaires américain vous êtes
désormais divorcés massimo j'ai dit
qu'il était organisateur d'événements
organisateurs de fêtes
mais il est aussi marieur il présente
des gens souvent et c'est massimo qui
vous a présenté votre jeu pas contenir
votre boyfriend actuelle oui championnat
italien il les a vu un génial
il est grand il écrit ponts et les
masses tout ce que n'est pas massimo
daniel sympa ah oui monsieur moi nous
paraît massimo nous parle de la cruauté
dans la tête
une personnalité absolument génial et
tous les deux c'est les meilleures zones
de la terre et de la famille tall est un
ami d'enfance elle lui
oui oui je connais non j'ai collé laissé
sa mère et moi je terminais ça mais
maman ne rêve pas parce que vous dites
ma vie est plus agité que le plus agité
des romande aventure et c'est vrai c'est
vrai que la ville ivana trump est une
vie exceptionnelle
donc on va raconter un petit peu votre
votre vie si vous le voulez bien votre
nom de jeune fille c'est ivan à zenit
cheikhou zelnik zèle ni tchèque alors
vous êtes né au début c'est un petit peu
l'histoire de votre ami adriana karembeu
au départ c'est à dire il va n'a aînés
dans une ville qui s'appelle gottwald a
faim qui s'appelait gottwald of du nom
du premier président communiste de la
tchécoslovaquie gottwald clément gaulle
val est donc maintenant ça a changé de
nom s'appelle l'inma l'époque soit à
caudeval duff et alors c'est une ville
industrielle avec des odeurs de suis
comme ça c'est vraiment lorsqu'il faut
dire c'est que vous aviez une dictature
communiste et vous aviez une septième
surveiller votre famille était très
surveillée parce qu'une tante à vous en
48 en 1948 était parti donc
effectivement vous êtes partis vers le
sport est parti vers le ski justement
pour pouvoir voyager parce que sinon y
avait aucun moyen de voyager donc une
vie un peu quand même pas triste mais
une vie pas simple et pas facile en
tchécoslovaquie
vous lancez dans le ski 1 et d'ailleurs
ça vous a beaucoup appris le ski parce
que vous avez appris la ténacité pas ce
que vous dites quand on descend une
montagne sur deux bouts de bois ben ça
vous apprend à compter que sur vous même
et c'est peut-être ça qui a forgé votre
votre caractère si solide c'est vrai
alors la fin des études secondaires vous
tomber amoureuse d'un garçon qui était
un grand skieur tchèque qui s'appelle
georges siro vodka inquiets à l'époque
étudiant et puis là vous commencez quand
même à faire des photos volées à prague
à l'université charles commencé à faire
des photos de mode dans modhac chose
pour moi la chose la plus importante
c'est tel est l'enseignement l'éducation
pierre prêche ce qui est bien sûr pour
l'équipe nationale
tchécoslovaque et puisse gagner un petit
peu d'argent à côté comme je pouvais
mais dans le monde de la mode en effet
en étant mannequin une vie difficile
parce qu'ils avaient peur n'est pas le
droit de se teindre les cheveux les
patins du riez pas de cinéma n'est pas
discothèque en face c'était quand même
une vie assez discuté que ça je peux
vous dire il y en avait pas et alors un
jour vous émigré au canada et vous
rejoignez donc votre fiancée de l'époque
qui s'appelait georges siro bat k comme
je les dis et qui lui a ouvert un
magasin de ski au canada
alors vous allez là-bas bon vous donner
des cours de ski vous trouvez dans une
agence de mannequins à montréal et là où
je vis le fric c'est chic
un jour vous êtes dans une boîte de nuit
à new york avec une amie vous cherchez
une table
vous trouvez pas table que personne ne
vous connaît et le garçon qui vous aide
qui vous aide à trouver une table c'est
donald ram j'ai senti ma seconde épaule
puis j'aime pas trop ça alors j'ai
regardé derrière moi et il y avait ce
type absolument superbe et il m'a dit je
m'appelle tonneau tschopp et il m'a dit
vous avez du mal à trouver
j'ai regardé mon ami je lui ai dit on a
les bonnes nouvelles et une nouvelle
manette c'est quoi la bonne nouvelle
bonne nouvelle c'est qu'on va avoir une
table très très vite parce que ce
monsieur là il collait bien restaurant
la mauvaise nouvelle c'est que il va
venir s'asseoir avec nous et c'est comme
ça que j'ai rencontré de la lys et acier
avec vous et votre ami et en quelques
mois plus tard vous signez votre premier
contrat prénuptial
et après vous êtes mariée avec lui
d'ailleurs c'est vrai vous avez signé un
contrat par an un contrat de mariage par
an il y avait des contrats très
rapproché je comprends pas ça on
changeait les contrats nous n'ont pas
tous les ans
peut-être tous les cinq ou six ans nous
changer les contraint c'est beau l'amour
mais alors j'ai vraiment travaillé
beaucoup et se mérite tout ce que j'ai
rien c'est quelque chose résolument tout
le monde croit ivana est devenu riche
après son divorce avec donald trump est
en fait je travaille énormément vous
étiez très impliqué dans les affaires
donald freinte vous dirigez un casino à
atlantic city qui était l'un des plus
rentables du monde s'est dirigé le plaza
athénée à new york vous avez été élu
hôtelière de l'année donc c'est vrai que
c'est oui c'est un peu si c'est un peu
énervant toujours de les gens pensent
que vous êtes devenus riches seulement
après votre divorce
alors bon sur votre histoire d'amour
avec donald trump c'est vrai qu'au début
ils avaient des aventures vous ferme un
petit peu les yeux au début vous faites
ce qu'on appelle en france la politique
de l'autruche et je sais qu'au moment du
divorce elle a conclu que son mari était
fidèle tous les temps à m vous étiez au
courant quand même de l'aventuré votre
mari avec marc ameil pulse vous étiez au
courant je ne savais pas j'étais pas
je n'ai découvert ben le soir de noël à
aspen dans un restaurant où on est en
train de skier c'est la quête de famille
et quand j'ai appris qu'il avait raison
avec une autre femme une autoroute et à
aspen moi j'ai trouvé ça arrive et quand
j'ai découvert les la liaison j'ai
immédiatement demandé le divorce pansu
d'être un petit peu bourgeoise un petit
plat traditionalistes et pour moi ça
calme tout était cassé vous voyez ça
pouvait pas continuer on y trouve
différents massimo lui peut continuer et
recommencer on va commencer ma part
peut-être que les choses sont
différentes entre les hommes et les
femmes je ne sais pas mais sinon je les
proches toujours arriver à ma dette de
trop bourgeoise dans sa mentalité et là
des choses très très strict
1 est ce que c'est vrai ivana trump est
ce que c'est vrai ce qu'on raconte dans
la presse de nous le dire c'est que vous
êtes donc dans ce restaurant au moment
de noël à aspen et que marc ameil pulse
arrive dans le restaurant s'approche de
vous et vous dis j'aime votre mari c'est
vrai ça et un stade cela oui oui c'est
vrai santa barbara
c'était hélas c'est ce qui s'est passé
exactement ce qui s'est passé si vous
avez appelé également ce même c'est à la
veille de noël
en fait tout ça s'est fait en peluche
demande mes trois enfants
donc c'était pas très agréable et alors
là évidemment vous commencez à parler
divorce je vous dit je le laisse partir
mais ça va lui coûter cher alors vous
avez un petit peu dit le problème aussi
qu'il ya eu c'est que à cette époque là
ça va aller vite il l'a voulu tu vas
l'avoir
j'avais une question à poser mois mais
est ce que c'est vrai qu'il vous a donné
ses testicules en boucle d'oreille
qu'est-ce qu'il veut donner gentiment de
la traductrice est en train de non
seulement des diamants c'est le monde et
diam seulement des diamants bon garçon
alors quatorze 14 millions de 14
millions de dollars
un appartement à new york une maison
amara lago en face ça va quoi et alors
là après cette histoire vous dites je
vais pas me laisser emporter
vous dites je vais pas me laisser
emporter dans le tourbillon du désespoir
vous décidez de vous battre
c'est que non je vais pas me coucher et
mourir c'est exactement ce qui s'est
passé j'ai une mona la ville c'est
merveilleux je vais pas mais c est mon à
conviction c'est qu'il faut pas regarder
le passé le passé il est fini c'est
terminé il faut regarder vers l'avenir
et alors là il ya ça c'est la première
vengeance c'est que vous avez gagné 10
fois ce qui vous avait donné lors du
lors du divorce mais surtout lui avec
marla michaels il se marie avec elle et
ils divorcent quand même temps après
13,2 en un an à peu près un ange points
et l'algérie avec
finalement tout est bien qui finit bien
les spas et l'arrimage pour cette
identité six femmes non c'est beaucoup
d'argent 1
on évalue votre fortune je pas si c'est
vrai à 45 millions de dollars vous avez
combien de maisons ivan à environ 5 plus
le yacht qui s'appelle le ivan ah oui
j'avais dit elliott vous dit
finalement on combien de steak est ce
qu'on peut manger dans une journée alors
quand on est riche on mange combien de
steaks par jour quand on est riche
combien en revanche de ya beaucoup de
gens qui sont vraiment obsédé de faire
de l'argent et encore de l'argent est
toujours largement et moi je connais
beaucoup d'amis qui sont des
millionnaires des billionaire des trios
nerfs il travaille il faut bien que
travailler jamais une ambition pour la
famille les enfants c'est simplement
alors combien c'est qu'en effet et pour
manger par jour combien de voitures
ouais combien de maisons maisons il faut
s'arrêter et puis se détendre un petit
peu quand on a on n'a jamais vu un
coffre fort suivre un corbillard alors
serge maintenant j'en ai posé à ivana
trump la question qui tue
alors il va la trempe questions
importantes si demain matin
donald trump revenez vers vous et vous
proposer de reprendre la vie de famille
avec vos enfants
il y en oublie tout on se remet ensemble
tous et on reprend une vie normale tu me
pardonnes excuse moi est ce que vous
seriez d'accord est ce que vous lui
diriez oui ou non à ce stade je dirais
non
je suis vraiment convaincu d'abord parce
que je suis amoureuse d'un autre homme
et puis y est tellement de mal qui a été
fait bon bien sûr je suis remonté et
maintenant les enfants ont réussi à
atteindre un stade de paix paisible et
moi je veux continuer avec ma vie et
puis donald a des intérêts qu'ils sont
différents à manger des intérêts
différents je passe beaucoup de temps en
europe je jouis de ma vie je fais des
choses différentes et lui il continue à
travailler travailler travailler vont
intéresser milliards et c'est parfait
pour moi ce n'est plus fait pour nos
groupes aucun espoir on allume art
[Applaudissements]
alors dans cette émission comme je le
disais tout à l'heure le public mais pas
seulement là pour faire ça il peut aussi
poser des questions qui me pose une
question ivana trump vous je vous en
prie bruce willis n'a rien à craindre
mon garçon tu n'as rien à quoi bon soir
il y en a je voudrais savoir
juridiquement aux états unis ce que
c'est plus simple parce que ça a été
plus simple pour vous de vous marier ou
divorcer en fait se marier très
difficile il suffit d'aller à la selle
cassée vous complètement grillé
instantanément sabots couteau dans 10
dollars à peu près par contre un divorce
assez difficile notamment lorsqu'il ya
des intérêts monétaire en jeu et les
hommes
ils sont mais très rendant ça c'est
typique des hommes ils sont radins aller
au moins en amérique il ya quand même
des lois et surtout on qu'elle fournit à
new york
tout ça ça dépend des estars américain
normalement la femme épouse qui était
borce doit obtenir la moitié des biens
communs mais là on commence par un
combat parce que les hommes ils
commencent à recruter des avocats et dit
non non je veux pas payer et à free
iliad et les gaspillages d'argent un tel
gaspillage de temps finalement ceux qui
s'en mettent plein la poche
ce sont les avocats quelqu'un d'autre
vous venez mon petit la voilà bonsoir
j'aimerais sur les commandes fabienne
numéro de portable voire ivan à 6 avec
donald trump vous avez fait un mariage
d'amour ou un mariage de raison
j'ai rencontré donald j'avais 28 ans lui
il en avait 30
on en sait marier par amour ça
d'ailleurs pendant 12 ans était un
mariage est tellement super league avec
deux ans difficiles non c'était
absolument un mariage dans la bouche et
c'est pas mal c'est quelqu'un
d'intelligent du moins j'espère je
travaille beaucoup
j'aurais pu trouver n'importe quel homme
que je viens de trouver un enjeu les
mariés absolument pas un amour merci
est ce que quelqu'un veut poser une
question ils en train quant aux rues ou
par la non ou oui venez vous une jolie
robe van assche qui il est et thierry
mugler j'adore il est vraiment ce n'est
sa question je crois donc c'était votre
question
rappelez-vous yoann yoannn alors posez
votre question est très belle massimo
c'est l'école gardia massimo fait
[Applaudissements]
alors ma question était la suivante je
n'ai pas d'appartement
non merci est-ce que d'après votre
expérience
l'argent fait le bonheur je mentirais si
on disait que l'argent n'ont pas
d'importance
l argent des jolies voitures des maisons
plus jolie des vacances plus intérieure
mais non ça ne vous achète pas l'amour
ça sera ma réponse merci beaucoup merci
beaucoup il en a 30
si le fric c'est chic alors maintenant
on va passer une petite interview il va
n'a très sympathique c'est un petit jeu
un espace sans importance ça s'appelle
l'interview alerte aux roses
[Musique]
non
bien calé ivana trump votre première
pensée quand vous vous trouvez en face
d'un homme séduisant ragab a quasiment
nul et on a envie de les tenir dans ses
bras
et puis le troisième se départir il y
avait de l'eau glacée on a envie de
tenir dans ses bras
ça vous donne une idée peu près mais je
me dis pas la troisième qu'elle est
quel est pour vous le quel est pour vous
il va naître un italien s'est mal passé
elle a dit que des usines dame attention
je vais pas dire moi aussi qu'elle est
calé pour vous il va la trempe le lieu
idéal pour une étreinte et on sait
jamais ce qui va se passer après olalala
c'est et essayiste le king c'est à
bergame et ses toits qu'elle adore
surtout avec les italiens ont annoncé
qu'à la madone attention à la
consultation
c est ce que vous préférez draguer ou
vous faire draguer bon c'est toujours
l'homme qui doit me draguer j'espère que
tout ça c'est alors de venir à moi c'est
ça qui est ça qui leur plaît aux hommes
les jeunes il aime travailler pour venir
vous chercher
est ce que vous préférez largué vous
faire larguer non non c'est moi qui
l'équipe
ah c'est vous que j'ai dit et ça il faut
vous draguer mais après c'est vous qui
quittait aussi les précédents mais c'est
pas gentil mais je dis attention
elle secoue préféré embrasser ou qu on
vous embrasse
j'aime bien les embrasser les hommes on
sent que j'aime pas ça c'est eux qui m'a
brasse mais j'aime bien passé j'ai chaud
j'ai changé
les blondes bien alors des problèmes
est ce que tu vas avoir des ennuis
est-ce que no problemo ivana trump est
ce que vous conservez un fantasmes
inavouables en france
bien sûr je ne fais pas l'admettre ne
vais pas me confesser est ce que vous
croyez que des fantasmes et ses
fantasmes
eh bien il reste en essayant de vous
souvent on essaie de lévis vous essayez
pas de vivre tous vos fantasmes quand
vous vous trouvez ça plus sexy de les
garder en vous
plutôt que de les vivre c'est les deux à
gérer les deux dernières questions ivana
trump à coire connaissez-vous la passion
qui s'éteint les solutions d'abord ça
dépend de la personne
si on parle d'une véritable relation
bien sûr je crois que ce sont des signes
peut-être un peu et on a moins de faire
l'amour au lieu de faire tous les jours
qu'on le fait tous les deux jours on
vient toujours en catégorie mollahs est
moins bien il est non à tout d'un coup
on vous voyez votre homme qui se teint
les cheveux qui se fait couper les
cheveux qui fait des choses différentes
de ce qui fait d'habitude il ya des
signes qui font qu'on sait qu'un homme
et maison par exemple par exemple il
rentre tard à la maison
bon c'est pas ce qui m'est arrivé un
moment là vous êtes de bons conseils
merci
aussi la preuve
fish merci beaucoup vous restez avec
nous je reçois maintenant l'une des
comédiennes les plus doués de sa
génération
ouais si sandrine kiberlain
bonsoir sandrine ivana trump massimo
gargia cas d'olivier sandrine kiberlain
donc ivana qui est l'une des jeunes
comédiennes les plus doués de sa
génération
elle a 32 ans elle a fait 22 films orgie
signer quelques d'abord avoué commencer
les appareils un rôle énorme enfin
cyrano de bergerac les patriotes qui
était un film très important pour vous
il ya eu avant les patriotes et après
les patriotes d'eric rochant l'irrésolu
les gens normaux n'ont rien
d'exceptionnel un héros très discret
beaumarchés le septième ciel à vendre
rien sur robert de moniteurs la fausse
suivante love me et que géniale idée
laetitia masson voilà à quoi donc il y
en a d'autres encore alors au sujet de
l'ovni qu'est votre film précédent vous
jouiez à l'époque avec donc que géniale
idée vous dites j'ai toujours aimé les
variétés façon hessel c'est cette époque
comme celle c'est cette façon qu'ils
avaient d'être ensemble toute cette
bande
maintenant il ya patrick fiori je vois
pas ce que tu vas contre patrick ben je
sais me
on fabrique qu'est-ce que vous avez
quatre batteries qu'aujourd'hui il est
sûrement très gentil mais c'est pas
c'est pas la même chose c'est pas dans
la merde non mais je confirme je ne sais
pas la même chose patrick fiori donné
l'idée voilà mais enfin bon c'est à dire
qui n'est pas dit non non il n'a à ma
place to tell you must do date
son regard des missions et vincent et
d'armes en adhérant à ces connards qui
font ça dans quand tu es bien et pas
bien alors évident j'avais des bras trop
court
alors mercredi un film qui sort qui
s'appelle tout va bien on s'en va de
claude mouriéras ce qui était présenté
d'ailleurs la quinzaine des réalisateurs
à cannes avec miou-miou avec vous bien
sûr miu miu
natacha régnier michel piccoli alors le
pitch l'histoire jeu vidéo guide si je
me trompe pas c'est trois soeurs qui
vivent ensemble jusque là c'est juste et
le père réapparaît 15 ans après jusque
là cjue très curieux voilà c'est ça et
puis un jour le père revient les parties
depuis 15 ans alors il revient lui sans
s'excuser sans se justifier il ya une
scène assez enfin le plein de scènes
fortes dans ce film est une assez forte
c'est peut-être votre votre mec comme ça
qui vous dit à quelqu'un la porte
d'aller ouvrir vous trouvez en face de
votre père qui jouait donc par michel
piccoli et vous dites non y'a rien à
personne
vous êtes une dureté à ce moment-là vous
claquer la porte c'est fait c'est de
l'amour en même temps sinon elle aurait
aucune réaction à la haine c'est aussi
de l'amour mais en fait oui partir
quinze ans vous imaginez le retour d'un
père on a chacune nos réactions dans le
film et puis donc la plus jeune et très
idéaliste
une folle de son père donc elle
l'accueille à bras ouverts la plus
grande avec le plus de choses sûrement
que moi et donc à peut-être plus de
facilité à le revoir et moi c'est sait
beaucoup de choses qui ressortent
et beaucoup finalement d'amour à la fin
on comprend que cette façon de rejeter
c'est aussi de l'amour quoi ça prouve
que l'amour peut dépasser en tous les
cas n'importe quel grand coeur vous il
ya une scène que j'aime beaucoup
une autre scène c'est là je les aime
bien c'est quand la benne ou python et
de vaud pourquoi il se met torse nu oui
d'accord mais j'ai pas dis que c'est la
deuxième voie là d'ailleurs au passage
oui sont pas mal à elles sont très bien
faites et était alors moi je parle
maintenant ils sont uniquement ses
mérites et non sérieusement je peux ou
bien je peux vous le dire après tout
c'est un compliment je peux vous dire
que vous avez dessin magnifique merci
des 95 b extrêmement fermé vous êtes
connaisseurs non vous avez des samanides
ans si vous êtes reconnaissants que vous
avez le way to danger non je vais vous
dire la vérité j'ai vu le film sur
cassette donc j'ai repassé la semaine ça
non mais vous avez touché la voisine
pour faire des changements voire tuer
l'intéressé n'a voyagé en bus comme on
peut dites moi ton quand il m'a parlé de
votre visite la plus après ce sera fini
oui justement vous êtes très bien d'être
agitée alors vous étiez très complexée
étant petit
parce que vous appelez la girafe mois
pour moi une girafe c'est très beau déjà
c'est très gracieux ça a des longs cils
et plus et donc je le prends pas mal et
la girafe c'était les taches de rousseur
et les taches de rousseur j'ai jamais
vécu ça mal mais
puis je me trouve très belle le met le
nez vous a demandé à briller les
journées c'est là que j'ai commencé à me
préoccuper de mon nez mais avant ça les
gens dont il faut se faire refaire le
nez et ses reins et puis comme il était
avant normalement on exclut tous les
témoignages qui s'appelle tout va bien
on s'en bat magnéto
[Musique]
un éléphant mais pas du tout c'est un
petit prêt le remboursera quand il sera
devenu très célèbre union non plus je
suis pas bien
[Musique]
qu'est ce que tu vois que tu l'as acheté
vivent pas vous mais moi
[Musique]
pourquoi
le
m
[Musique]
je
voilà tout l'année en 120 des voeux de
mariage avec miou-miou natacha régnier
sandrine kiberlain michel piccoli à
partir de mercredi sur vos écrans dites
moi alors ce qui a forgé votre caractère
parce qu'on parlait tout à l'heure
d'ivana trump on disait ce qui a formé
son caractère puisqu'une femme d'à fin
dur ce qui a formé son caractère c'est
en fait qu'elle descendait à 140 à
l'heure sur des skis à l'âge de 12 ans
et donc effectivement ça vous ça vous
apprendre c'est pas ça vous c'est pas ça
vous vous grands-parents ofi la pologne
à van gaal sont bien en france avant
guerre et vous dites ils ont vécu la
pire des injustices évidemment et je les
ai jamais entendu se plaindre et
finalement ça a été une ligne de
conduite pour vous oui bon on n'a pas le
droit je trouve de se plaindre quand on
a en face de soi des gens aussi
courageux qui ont fait leur vie sont
arrivés ils parlaient que dis je parlais
pas un mot de français
fallait acheter du pain sens vraiment il
savait rien c'est ma mère qui en
grandissant a appris à son père à
conduire d'avenir à écrire ici en
prendre tes coin 36 37 noms 33 23 mai
lors ce qui est terrible c'est que c'est
pas gai de repartir en auvergne pendant
la guerre mais que ce n'était pas fini
en plus c'était pas le le havre de paix
qu'ils espéraient alors pas besoin d'une
enfance dans un cocon assez alors votre
père après on verra après s'il ya
d'autres choses avec votre terme enfin
disons qu'il était au départ un expert
comptable il était restaurateur et à 15
ans j'aimerais bien savoir pourquoi vous
commencez à les roder du côté du cours
florent d' de francis huster qui vous
pousse à peine ma mascotte d'ailleurs
comment comment quel a été le
déclencheur de ça mais je pense que
c'est le cinéma en allant voir des films
j'avais déjà des parents cinéphiles et
une tante sikkim amené voir beaucoup de
films je me souviens d enchaîner
d'hitchcock qui avait été un choc et des
choses comme ça et donc des là
seconde je voulais absolument faire du
théâtre c'est pourtant avec huster au
conservatoire avec mesguich par donc
voila vous fait vos débuts au cinéma
plein de films il ya eu l'irrésolu dont
vous avez rencontré vincent lindon je
vais retrouver après dans le 7ème ciel
il a fini par vous épousez en 98 mariage
surprise la mairie du xvième mariage
surprise ça doit être génial
voilà voilà donc comment il ya surprise
comment ça peut être alors laissé
reprenant mes temps il arrive il dit on
va au restaurant puis en fait c'est la
mairie oui c'est un peu ça
mais voilà en approche à mes proches non
je vais pas vous demander plus merci je
suis quelqu'un de très discret tout le
monde le sait est d'ailleurs en fait
sandrine vous cherchez à retrouver comme
beaucoup de jeunes filles vous cherchez
à retrouver dans vie affective dans
l'audi maritale ce que vous avez connu
un petit peu dans votre enfant c'est à
dire cette espèce de stabilité de
fidélité de ouais enfin j'essaie d'être
interview la vraie de vraie question
j'essaie d'être heureuse avec avec
oui avec l'homme avec qui j évidemment
vous reproduisez moi je n'ai pas
l'impression non plus de reproduire
parce que
je suis moi je me moins que ça ressemble
à une famille enfin comment dire le côté
tous collés comme ça que des berlingots
chapelet de saucisses tout ça on n'était
pas comme ça
alors bon on vous fait du cinéma on fait
aussi du théâtre alors en 96 donc vous
faites une pièce s'appelle le roman de
lulu et gérard darmon et là je vais
raconter cette histoire parce que c'est
incroyable cette histoire un jour
sandrine kiberlain reçoit par la poste à
une pièce de théâtre le script d'une
pièce de théâtre et c'est l'histoire
d'un quinquagénaire qui est food
amoureux d'une jeune fille de 25 ans
elissa elle est bouleversée elle est
même un petit peu choqué et puis elle
lit la pièce et vous comprenez que c'est
votre père qui a écrit la pièce dire que
son père en fait sous le pseudonyme de
david des cas avait écrit cette pièce et
vous dites c'est bizarre d'ailleurs de
dire des mots d'amour qui ont été écrits
par sont pas parfaitement mais quand
vous débutez votre père qu'il y avait
des mots d'amour des mots de cul des
mots des mots qu'on oui c'était
compliqué comment j'ai su que c'était
comment vous avez trouvé que c'est
possible mais à la deuxième page en fait
enfin au fur et à mesure je me disais
mais elle fait des claquettes j'ai fait
des claquettes c'est bizarre le style
d'écriture et je savais qu'il écrit vers
il avait écrit plusieurs pièces
il a connu ma mère entendue terre oui
enfin c'était quelqu'un de très
passionné par ça et je pense qu en me
voyant évoluer là dedans et ça a dû lui
donner envie de s'offrir les battues
pour monter la pièce marie que vous
l'avez jouer donc avec gérard darmon et
ce qui est encore plus magnifique c'est
que le 22 novembre
voilà sort le film ça c'est génial
histoire avec thierry lhermitte et
claire keim
donc voilà donc c'est vraiment une belle
histoire film c'est très très bien bien
alors on va faire une petite interview
vous êtes d'accord
je suis d'accord on va faire une petite
interview première fois
[Musique]
tout le monde bouge pour le jingle ce
n'importe quoi votre premier souvenir
vous souvenez votre premier souvenir
alors je ris quand j'étais déguisé en
fait à l'école votre premier choc
mon premier choc tu t'es vue on fait
quand t'es quoi tu t'es vu en fait quand
on m'a transformé quand j'ai transformé
quelqu'un avec la baguette
parce que schilling sur very much more
ya un petit délai il ya un petit délit
chacun quand tu dis quelque chose de
temps qu'on traduise et où qu'elles se
marre de me la faire du live dealer qui
vient de vivre sa vie'
qu'est-ce qui vient animer votre premier
péché ça vous vous en souvenez vous
est-ce que c'était un péché
j'ai coupé les cheveux d'une fille fasse
un passé pas empêcher ça vous la
trouviez trop joli ça simplement parce
qu'elle allait appliquer un mec
alors oui non ça je sais c'est un peu ça
s'est un peu c'est carrément un péché
s'est pressée cheveux dites moi vous
votre votre premier amour
oui
la belle sandrine ça lui rappelle cette
chanson ça vous rappelle que très
rarement et là elle a du mal à l'air de
rien elle sourit il est tombé pour sa
ligne c'est quelque chose de très très
dur de crêpes
elle peut plus écouté cette chanson très
très fort elle sourit parce qu'elle est
forte
c'est vous qui l'avait larguée oui parce
qu'ils gagnent à l'argot si on est tombé
sur un os 5.0 caylar dj vous êtes
d'europe centrale toutes les deux comme
elle s'appelle est venu tchèque
oui c'est vrai ces deux points communs
vous êtes d'europe centrale toutes les
deux vous êtes des pays en fait de
décommander mon premier livre de poésie
et sylvana non non je sais plus qui
parle a dit tu peux lui demander une
adresse web c'est sa banane
il faut comparer ce que la madame
première cuite
oui un réveillon de nouvel an il ya
longtemps bien longtemps
ouais avec ma soeur premier pétard
jamais non ça une taffe comme twin donne
et ça m'a fait cracher la fumée voilà
rien dit c'est ça votre première chance
dans la vie qui vous la donner je pense
que ce sont mes parents
premier échec c'est quoi
premier échec que ça peut
moi je veux pas très sympa mais je te
regarde la tv
non je dirais l'irrésolu parce que c'est
vraiment un film que j'aime pas ah ouais
et la première chose que vous faites le
matin vous réveillant je vais voir ma
fille
[Musique]
il va là
alain qui ont tous péri et les huit
longueurs because de gars comme ça et je
vais laisser one man show you will love
it voici le numéro un des ventes
frédéric beigbeder
frédéric bonsoir je n'ai que vous
connaissez donc il va n'attrape nous
avait été jet setteur vous frédéric amor
amour amor j'avais ma photo dans vogue
et tout bon sens vous connaissez vous
aviez déjà très millions d'euros c'est
donc titré dérive
vous connaissez sandrine kiberlain je
suis un peu amoureux d'elle depuis
longtemps l'une des meilleures actrices
de sa génération
mais quand est ce qu'on va arrêter de
dire de sa génération mais je vois
sensations c'est bizarre ce truc
les conduisent de tous les temps
l'actrice pouvoir passer une génération
je suis pas de la génération de ceux des
autres une des meilleures actrices de
livres une bière à gries de l'île de ré
parce que ce qu'il faut dire maintenant
si j'ai demandé à frédéric beigbeder
devenir ce soir c'est pas parce qu'il
est numéro 1 des ventes avec son livre
99 francs
c'est parce que cet été il a vu sur la
plage de l'île de ré ce que nous allons
tous voir parce que vous allez tous voir
mercredi dans le film de claude
mouriéras ce je ne sais pas d'eric ne
soyez pas menteur vous me l'avez dit au
téléphone
vous voulez dire les le corps sublime de
sandrine
le 95 sur la plage oui et c'est une
femme épanouie c'est une femme
d'aujourd'hui c'est très bien je me
demandais pourquoi y aller en vacances à
l'île de ré c'est très chic il y avait
emmanuelle béart aussi à huy sont tous
tenus de stars là bas tandis que
sandrine on vous êtes non torse nu alors
pdg minutes à terre voilà
le
donc frédéric alors bon votre livre vous
c'est pourquoi j'ai enlevé la couverture
un parce que je trouve que la couverture
que votre éditeur amis par-dessus fait
penser que c'est un peu du big business
est un livre fait pour vendre alors
qu'en fait c'est un roman chez grasset
de bonne qualité est vraiment littéraire
et le fait que c'est un livre qui a été
saluée quand même par françois
nourissier par welbeck par josyane
savigneau au monde par jean garcin enfin
se dire bon voilà quoi
ils vous ont dit tout ça quand vous êtes
allé dans leur émission non non non je
préfère dans l'avion n'a pas lui qui
déjà ne lit pas les livres pour mieux
encore vous êtes en tête de la liste des
prix s'est enfin je suis sur plusieurs
listes de prix dans toutes les listes de
prix c'est vrai enfin rempart d'une
adaptation au cinéma
oui beaucoup oui ce serait ce serait pas
mal
vous avez droit à un triomphe romain
chez vous
c'est moi ivana vous connaissiez ça le
triomphe romain
enfin pas s'étonner gilles et le succès
on termine sur le yacht d'ivana trump
après une subtile et c'est foutu pour
toi c'est foutu pour calme et ça fait 3
heures je la travaille comme en bois tu
sais en bois tu devras depuis 13h et
d'ailleurs qui arrivent et qui ramassent
le morceau et je suis le bellâtre et va
chez le coiffeur
aulas
elle m'a dit à leur sujet les sharks et
timide oui c'est incroyable enfin vous
avez un succès extraordinaire avec ce
livre vous arrivez ici va la drogue chez
nous alors vous appelez votre livre 99
francs pourquoi parce qu'on est dans la
civilisation de l'argent et que il ya
plus besoin de trouver un titre il
suffit de mettre le prix c'est ça c'est
embêtant parce que vous vous dites les
réponse est non si vous voulez je vous
dirai comment on fait avec je fais comme
les autres animateurs alors pourquoi 99
france frédéric beigbeder et bien parce
que nous vivons dans une civilisation
marchande et que par conséquent il est
inutile de trouver un titre pour un
livre il suffit de mettre le prix dessus
voilà fait c'était sais pas si c'était
mieux que deux vendu ce soir il en vend
dix mille pardons
c'est un peu on va en reparler vous êtes
un peu en guerre dans ce bouquin contre
le veau d'or incarné par dans votre
livre la publicité terre les annonceurs
les agences la world company mais le
fait que grasset votre éditeur
appartiennent aux marchands d'armes
matra ça vous a pas gêné non au
contraire mais ce que je pense que c'est
une bombe et non ça c'est une réponse
tout préparé non non j'ai très mal hein
vous dites moi oui comme mon livre est
une bombe atomique c'est normal qu'il
soit édité chez matra bon mais le fait
que matra fabrique des armes qui tuent
des gens qui tuent des enfants ça vous
gêne pas écouté c'est un livre là-dessus
c'est à dire c'est un lille sur le fait
qu'on est tous prisonniers de ce monde
qu'il n'y a plus d'alternative que nous
sommes donc à la fois victimes et
complice d'un système et tous les
personnages du livre
finalement la pub essaye de leur faire
aimer leur prison ils n'arrivent pas à
s'en échapper
je suis comme ça vous êtes comme ça on
est tous comme ça et la question c'est
ben est ce qu on a attendu de milan pour
ça voilà je vous répondrai toujours pas
la question là si c'est à dire que
je pense pas qu'ils soient ça
m'intéresse pas si vous venez d'écrire
un livre qui donne des leçons de morale
sans sens les a pas eu envie de les
connaître c'est le médiateur qui
n'appartiendraient pas un marchand
d'armes mais non mais ils appartiennent
tous à des grands groupes de
communication
mais si bien sûr il ya enfin je veux
dire le directeur si ça appartient par
un marchand d'armes
oui oui c'est vrai si vous voulez mais
enfin je pense que ça change pas grand
chose et que l'idée du lit n'est
justement pas d'être quelque chose de
vertueux de pure etc je crois que c'est
un livre un pur dans un monde qu'il est
aussi une vision cynique d'un monde
qu'il est aussi voile avait lu sandrine
vive et frédéric alors l'idée en fait au
départ c'est michel houellebecq donc il
vous a amenée sur cette voie c'est à
dire que au moment où j'ai publié mon
roman précédent l'amour dure trois ans
houellebecq qui avait beaucoup aimé ce
livre m'a dit
c'est bien de parler de ton divorce des
boîtes de nuit le thé ecstasy et tout ça
mais
tu travailles depuis un certain temps
dans dans un métier qui est un métier
important et personne n'écrit là dessus
peut-être que ce serait intéressant de
faire un roman sur la pub
au départ j'ai pensé que c'était une
idée qui en viendraient tout le monde et
puis j'ai commencé à prendre des notes
et dans les réunions souvent les clients
voyez un créatif qui notait ce qu'avec
jamais ce qui arrive jamais alors ils se
disaient oui puisque vous avez bossé là
dedans aussi
et ils vous disaient bravo frédéric
c'est bien vous prenez des notes serra
formidable atout fil à tout est dans le
livre maintenant
alors maintenant vous êtes reconnu enfin
vous avez écrit plein de bons livres
dont l'amour dure trois ans d'ailleurs
eh bien vous êtes reconnu comme un
écrivain à part entière pourquoi est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui une question que je
posais à patrick poivre d'arvor il ya
quelques semaines
pourquoi aujourd'hui en france
finalement le tout le monde d'être
écrivain le nec plus ultra c'est d'être
écrivain c'est à dire giscard d'estaing
voulais être écrivain mitterrand voulait
tu écrives un ppda va être écrivain
hervé claude va être écrivain
ivan a écrit trois lettres shahzad
car chazal va être écrivain pourquoi
dans la france d'aujourd'hui le le nec
plus ultra c'est d'être écrivain c'est
classe qu'en boîte arrive ça ne va pas
du tout ça ça ne marche pas du tout à
fait franchement moi déjà boys band ça
marche
non non alors faites vous avez été viré
de votre agence le jour de la saint
frédéric
oui pour ma fête et vous avez été numéro
un des ventes le jour de votre
anniversaire vous n'y voyez pas un signe
d'une chaussée sur quelque chose de
septembre 2000 je suis d'ailleurs
inquiet parce que vous savez
une phrase de wilde qui dit il ya deux
tragédies dans la vie d'un homme
l'une est de ne pas réaliser ses rêves
et l'autre et de les réaliser et je me
trouve dans une situation c'est vrai
assez angoissante je pense même que
cette émission et le début de ma
déchéance que après lundi prochain je
vais commencer à être un has been
vendredi mais non moins élevées xavier
chez drucker après bah voilà
j'avais planifié tout ça j'ai planifié
je pense que vendredi en huit je serai
re découvert je viendrai à une sorte d'
écrivains cultes comme jean jacques
schuhl comme jean jacques soûlât
effectivement bien alors il ya eu pas
mal de réactions sur votre lit des
réactions des publicitaires le patron de
votre agence de pub a dit que c'était un
ramassis de clichés et ce2 qui avait pas
de drogués dans la pub oui c'est un sens
c'est ça oui à deux choses insensées
dans la place
oui il ya un autre mystère s'appelle
christophe lambert c'est pas du tout le
l'acteur qui lui a dit effectivement
aussi qui avait pas de drogués dans dans
la pub énorme puisque et grands et alors
il vit alors ça ils ont tous cherché des
moyens de vous casser donc lui il a dit
où ils se sont big bill a jamais fait de
grandes campagnes
alors j'ai fait des très grandes
campagnes et alors le pire c'est ce
qu'ils vous disent à salut l'artiste à
sa meilleure campagne de pub c'est un
bouquin dont ils ont tout essayé pour
vous si ces gars là bien sûr pas vous
auriez été emmerdé si les publicitaires
davet et mais en même temps ce bouquin
on réduit souvent votre lit frédéric
beigbeder à un pamphlet contre la pub
en fait c'est quand même un livre plutôt
contre le marché c'est ça on vous vous
remettez en cause l'argent roi d'une
certaine façon non est ce que finalement
on parle beaucoup en ce moment dans la
presse des bobos vous connaissez les
bobos oui c'est des gens qui sont
bourgeois bohème c'est à dire j'achète
mes pompes chez berluti mais je veux tu
arrêtes laguiller ce qui est formidable
évidemment comme situation c'est très
confortable
est ce que vous vous croyez pas
finalement ce livre est aussi
l'expression de ça c'est à dire de cette
époque où finalement tout le monde
pensait à peu près comme josé bové enfin
là les gens qui pensent qu'en souvent
comme josé bové ont fait en même temps
ils font rien de concret pour que
l'utopie de beauvais puis se réalise et
je crois le
vrai sujet du livre effectivement c'est
à dire que j'ai l'impression qu'on ne
peut plus se révolter que on aujourd'hui
finalement la révolte est tellement
ridicule à cause de plein de choses à
cause de mai 68 qui n'a pas marché à
cause de la chute du mur de berlin
on vit dans un monde aujourd'hui où
finalement il faut être résignés ou
alors si jamais on critique on critique
tout en participant quoi et je ne vois
pas d'issue
si elle n'a pas dans sérieusement est-ce
qu'on pouvait pas qu'à un moment si on
veut changer les choses il faut prendre
les armes parce que vous croyez pas qu'à
un moment pour faire une révolution il
faut quand même descendre dans la rue
parce que sinon ce sont je rappe ah non
je crois pas dans mon roman il ya une
scène de terrorisme ya une scène où ils
vont rendre visite à une actionnaires
des fonds de pension en amérique et où
je crois que j'essaie de montrer que
justement ce genre d'action aussi et est
absurde et la violence est absurde donc
je ne vois pas d'issue mais ça n'est pas
mon rôle en même temps moi je suis juste
romancier je suis pas un du cip en
théoricien ni un philosophe
mais est ce que finalement sérieusement
est-ce que le fait pas arrivé à
envisager la violence
c'est pas une question de classe sociale
parce que on peut et peut-être imaginer
comme dans la bande dessinée de gb qui
s'appelait l'enim lancer les choses vont
s'écrouler un jour un matin que tout le
monde en même temps sans se concerter va
dire j'arrête je vais plus au bureau ça
m'emmerde je jette mon téléphone
portable jusqu'à traiter les jeux je
casse ma carte de crédit
je suis assez optimiste pour penser que
les gens vont en avoir marre de vivre
comme ça un jour et c'est eux pas si
c'est pas si idiot de penser ça parce
que en union soviétique c'est un peu ce
qui s'est passé c'est à dire que sans
effusion de sang
finalement un empire totalitaire s'est
arrêtée de tourner dû lui toutes les
critiques qui sont parus sur votre livre
viennent une âme xp d'eric neuhoff qui
n'est pas négatif sur votre livre il dit
en parlant de votre vie frédéric
beigbeder
finalement c'est cette génération qui
met deux bords à toutes les sauces c'est
à dire le situationnisme à toutes les
sauces et il dit il raconte comme
personne mais il pense comme tout le
monde c'est une phase vous auriez pu
écrire d'ailleurs assez bien balancer
comme ça
mais est-ce que vous n'êtes pas le
sentiment finalement pensé un peu comme
tout le monde aujourd'hui c'est à dire
de de remettre en cause l'argent roi
mais finalement de rester dans le
système et de ne rien faire pour le
détruire
mais je ne vois pas d'issue je veux dire
je trouve que ça sa phrase est très
juste et qu'il a raison je crois que ce
qui est inquiétant c'est que tout le
monde pense ça et que personne ne fait
rien passé et ce qui va se passer là
qu'ils sont plus limités charly oleg est
formidable c'est fini
[Musique]
bien alors vraie bd vous n'échapperez
pas une petite interview spéciale à vous
connaissez le portrait chinois le
portrait chinoise c'est si tu étais une
fleur je fais un myosotis moment et vous
c'est l'anti portrait chinois
[Musique]
moi
frédéric si vous étiez une rupture une
rupture d'anévrisme une injure
[ __ ] vous laisse entre un joueur
j'aime bien bas avec ma fille on s'est
fait arrêter une émission à cause de ça
si vous étiez une maladie j'étais une
maladie la tuberculose
pourquoi je trouve que c'est une maladie
romantique un deal à gérér louis maslies
des poumons coiffe tizi si vous étiez un
accident alors j'aime bien
j'aime bien l'accident de lady diana
sous le tunnel de l'alma
c'est pour ça que j'aimais les people en
fait c'est parce que finalement c'est
vers mende aujourd'hui je trouve que ça
remplace les tragédies grecques oui
c'est des personnages
shakespearien si vous étiez une guerre
la guerre du goût regard du goût un vice
la lecture comme disait larbaud le vice
impuni
une trahison 99 francs
oui c'est vrai c'est une belle une arme
la publicité un supplice le dernier
roman de christine angot aux frais dès
lors le nom le supplice n'ont passé la
brillante culture en face de christine
angot bah oui ça c'est pas assez
c'était pas une arme tout le monde
attendait ce bouillon de culture en se
disant et ça fait sale et non mais c'est
que c'est que c'est tout le monde était
était avait envie d'être ailleurs
ah oui et puis vous aussi vous pensez
folie si vous étiez une cicatrice une
césarienne est ce que c'est une
cicatrice qui donne la vie c'est joli
c'est une [ __ ]
ah oui c'est une bonne question
arnaud viviant si vous étiez un
dictateur
thierry ardisson gerald des gens
répondent ça quand je demande un [ __ ]
si vous étiez une infirmité
le coeur d'artichaut je vous étiez un
assassin mathieu kassovitz à microbes
un microbe c'est pas parce qu'il a
assassiné films de livres
il a fait un signe qui s'appelle comme
ça
ouais
un microbe un microbe un virus
informatique genre iloveyou vous cliquez
dessus il a écrit à ilo veyou ça a l'air
plutôt sympa et puis en fait ça fout en
l'air tout votre ordinateur
j'aimerais bien être un peu comme ça
quoi une torture les oeuvres complètes
de claire chazal sais pas si vous étiez
une humiliation
je trouve
l'impuissance ça fait qu'on il faut pas
dire ça à la télé mais pourquoi une très
humiliant de paris vers dans des allées
temps en temps se soucie ressassement
massimo gargia qu il ya risque dans
toutes les
[Musique]
dans toutes les situations massimo
assurer effectivement prime
you want to leave no we can't go elle va
sur son yacht
tara bat saint tropez pensons yotel var
sommes enfin bon voilà c'est à la
routine c'est un monde 1
c'est dur non j'ai encore plus la bête
tout à l'heure bien bien ivana thank you
for coming
il faut se plaisent surtout et viau in
my chaud j'étais ravi d'être là sur
saône
bonne chance avec votre chose jusqu'ici
ça va être une émission merci beaucoup
bien je reçois maintenant on va parler
maintenant un petit peu politique
sérieusement parce que par semaine avec
des trucs inferno vous avez vu vous avez
suivi toutes ces histoires de cassettes
vidéo avec mary qui parle de chirac
dominique strauss kahn qui sait plus où
il a mis cette cassette enfin c'est tout
ça est un petit peu quand même
insupportable donc on va en parler avec
le porte parole des verts jean luc
bennahmias
bonsoir jean que sandrine kiberlain
cannes
bonsoir soir sur monsieur g à quel poste
mais non ils aiment le foot en plus à
l'époque du mondial et le reste aussi du
sport thiney si vous voulez autant que
vous voulez apple les révéler tout sa
place est bien évidemment saint-etienne
oui bien sûr les verts patrick péris
bretons c'est après jean-luc ne te porte
parole des verts j'ai 46 ans vous vivait
maritalement avec une femme vous n'êtes
pas que c'est bon je ne suis pas pâques
c'est d'être concubin je déteste le
livre de houellebecq
car j'ai connu ma famille il ya 19 ans
de justement dans l'espace du possible
ce que dénonce monsieur houellebecq de
manière assez désastreuse je pense et il
a très mal vécu les années 70 c'est bien
sans problème mais moi ça n'est pas
miner en tous les cas voilà ça commence
il a très mal vécu sa vie je pensais des
mal baisées c'est que je ne suis pas
d'accord
poutre
bien alors les verts là par l'ondé
parlons un peu de vous là comment vous
réagissez à cette histoire de parce que
là quand même on est au fond du fond du
fond du trou là c'est à dire que dans
quelques cassettes qui sort je n'ai pas
la cassette méry l'avait vu que vous
avez vu son compte numérique et qui
balancent irak
et puis après on dit que c'est dominique
strauss kahn la cassette a été remise en
échange d'un abattement fiscal pour karl
lagerfeld enfin tout ça on sait pas si
c'est vrai ça c'est vrai enfin l on
s'est attardé soyons sérieux
98% des skate dans cette cassette que je
n'ai pas vu j'ai vu comme vous le monde
bien sûr que c'est vrai tout le monde
sait que c'est vrai les histoires de
l'opac à paris david de paris c'est vrai
les histoires de la commission des
marchés dans le conseil régional ile de
france c'est vrai tout le monde le sait
faisons la transparence totale par
rapport à tout cela et puis après on
verra s'il ya repentance il ya pas
repentance et puis on demandera de
rembourser mais je pense que la seule
solution
oui pour pas vous vous dites que
finalement cette cassette ne vient que
confirmer les travaux du juge halphen
une certaine façon de un certain nombre
de juges qui ont me semble-t-il du mal à
aller vite à faire justice et je crois
que c'est ça qu'on attend oui c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui c'est un peu difficile
pour vos pots pour les gens quoi de
savoir qu'on a pu faire un abattement
fiscal ce n'est pas encore une fois ci
c'est vrai mais de 250 millions à karl
lagerfeld simplement les changes d'une
cassette oui c'est dur pour les gens qui
payent leurs impôts qui viennent de
payer leur tiers là par exemple pour le
moment il est surtout ma mère un qu'il
ouvrait chez vous non pas vous avez
l'air décidé à le loueur aussi je cesse
pas de l'ouvrir ou moins connus parce
que j'étais journaliste moins connus oui
on dit souvent que les politiques se
décrédibilise en venant dans des
émissions comme celle ci où des
émissions comme celle de michel drucker
ou celle de karl zéro
est ce que vous croyez pas qu'ils se
décrédibilise encore plus en osant
parler comme l'a fait devedjian au
milieu de la semaine d' amnistie pascal
déjà une amnistie
monsieur devedjian et jupe à taper sur
tout le monde ce soir mais est un
démagogue de première il est capable
effectivement de dire le plus récent
contraire d'une semaine à l'autre
il a parié d'amnesty saint scandale et
monsieur debré qui lui n'est pas un
démagogue
comme chacun sait
à dix nous il y a dix qui a dit qu'il y
avait un ministre il a dit non personne
ne l'a dit ou rpr mais si oui il y
apparaît d'amnesty social amnistie
sûrement pas à mon avis ayant séjourné
du rpr roselyne bachelot qui disait il
serait temps qu'on s'occupe un peu des
vrais problèmes des français plutôt que
de cette cassette les vrais problèmes
des français madame bachelot je vous le
dis parce que j'aime bien c'est ça c'est
de savoir que nous on paye les impôts et
lagerfeld en échange d'une cassette on
lui supprime 250 millions d'impôts verts
vous êtes au gouvernement il ya la fonte
de la calotte polaire l'effet de serre
le réchauffement de la planète la
pollution atmosphérique tout ça qui a
entraîné par le monde dans lequel on vit
et vous continuez de croire encore que
vous avez un pouvoir alors que c'est
l'économie qui gouverne et pas la
politique
je crois que c'est aux politiques de
gérer l'ensemble de la cité et je crois
que c'est aux citoyens de faire est de
voter quand ils ont le droit de vote de
voter pour les pour les élus qu'ils
volent les hommes politiques quand vous
leur dites ça disent toujours qu'ils
sont impuissants que c'est pas eux que
c'est les hommes d'affaires en parlant
de droite votent donc les français ont
le droit de vote et non pas tellement
exercer donc le 24 septembre vous avez
déclaré que c'est une véritable claque
pour l'ensemble de la classe politique
c'est vide alors le référendum vous
évidemment vous auriez préféré qu'on
fasse voter les français sur la
proportionnelle parce que le scrutin
majoritaire handicap votre votre parti
sur le cumul des mandats sur le vote des
étrangers
enfin des choses qui auraient pu changer
quelque chose mais est ce que vous
croyez vraiment que les gouvernants ont
envie de poser aux français des
questions dont les réponses pour
échanger quelque chose moi je crois pas
moi je crois que oui si vous voulez
cette question là non la dernière en
date
on l'a vu ne fait pas remarquable enfin
sur le traité de maastricht qui était
quand même un vrai traiter d'une vraie
affaire à l'union européenne ça n'est
pas rien ou sur la nouvelle calédonie
c'étaient de vraies questions là avoue
une future bon monsieur chirac m'avait
reçues j'avais dit bon merci
responsables de partis politiques
je dis bon très bien le quinquennat tout
le monde est d'accord mais rajouter deux
ou trois questions les français ne sont
pas idiots sont pas imbécile
ils peuvent répondre à quatre questions
à la fois que c'est aux états unis
pendant les élections il ya cinq ans en
même temps que des élections
présidentielles il ya cinquante
questions qui tombe il y arriver' site
américain y arrive les français peuvent
y aille mais les verts bon vous aime
bien vous aimez bien les verts où on
vous aime bien mais là vous êtes un
petit peu les tenants les dindons de la
farce quand ya la crise des carburants
il ya la crise des carburants dominique
voilée votre patronat tous découvrent
sur lci à une heure du matin la teneur
des accords entre les routiers
gouvernement bon
noël mamère a dit d'ailleurs c'est un
bras d'honneur aux idées du parti alors
c'est un jeu de dupes c'est bien vous
faites rouler dans la farine
sérieusement sinon sinon je ne ferais
plus de politique je vous ne croyez pas
qu'on peut changer la société patron des
socialistes aujourd'hui le ps vous roule
dans la farine dont je ne crois pas je
crois que de toute façon cette majorité
plurielle telle qu'elle existe
aujourd'hui continuera à exister si
l'ensemble de ces composantes sont
prises au sérieux
je pense que les verts effectivement ne
sont pas assez prise au sérieux mais que
depuis trois ans nous sommes deux
gouvernements jamais autant un état de
l'union européenne ne s'est occupé de la
pollution de l'air de l'effet de serre
des transports est ce que vous vous
n'avez pas l'impression de la vallée
couleuvres sur couleuvres absolument pas
on avale effectivement dans ce temps des
compromis avec tout cela bien sûr on
avale des couleuvres la vie la vie est
faite d'avalanche de couleuvres alors
après rôle et on les digère on ne digère
pas je pense que nous avons une liberté
de ton et liberté de parole totale et
que nous devons l'utiliser
et je pense aussi que si nous voulons
changer la société il a transformé la
transformer pour que les gens avec
l'accord des gens pas contre les gens
quand j'entends parler de thaler de
révolution je pense que ces termes là ne
sont plus des termes d'aujourd'hui je
pensais si on veut changer les choses il
faut que les gens il faut que les gens
soient d'accord avec nous avec
l'ensemble avec ce qu'on propose
et donc c'est possible l'économie n'est
pas démocratique aujourd'hui il n'est
pas démocratique
alors que comment vous faites puisque
c'est l'économie qui comme un non parce
que je crois que le politique la
politique la vie de la cité l'ensemble
de la gestion démocratique fait que un
moment donné on peut reprendre la main
sur l'économique si on ne ne pense pas
faut tout arrêter
moi je sais pas mais je vois les cordes
voilée aux présidentielles de 95 elle
fait moins qu'en 4 que les écologistes
dans 95,04 n'y a pas intérêt électoral
être associé avec les socialistes
il n'y a pas d'intérêt politique parce
que sur le nucléaire sur les autoroutes
vers un gagné du tout attends pas vrai
non excusez moi ouais il ya eu de
grosses manifestations contre la
centrale nucléaire de superphénix c'est
super phénix cet engin absolument
dommageable extrêmement coûteux et très
dangereux est fermé et je peux vous
assurer que jamais tant que les verts
seront gouvernement il n'y aura de
relance du programme nucléaire en france
est ce que vous croyez pas que
finalement les verts soutiennent j'ose
pas uniquement pour avoir un groupe à
l'assemblée parce que tant qu'il y'aura
pas la proportionnelle vous aurez pas de
groupe à l'assemblée pour être 20 à
l'assemblée vous avez besoin de passer
par le ps est ce que vous ne croyez pas
que les le ps travaille avec les verts
uniquement pour être majoritaire en
france parce que sinon il ne le serait
pas ouais c'est vrai aussi pourquoi pas
essayer de créer les écologistes par les
verts soit une troisième force qui soit
ni à gauche ni à droite ni droite ni à
droite ni à gauche je n'y crois pas une
seule seconde je crois que le progrès la
façon de transformer la société
et forcément à gauche maintenant reste à
savoir quelle gauche effectivement alors
donc j'avais plein de problèmes internes
chez les verts sont infernales parce que
vous êtes tout petit petit petit et vous
avez plein de problèmes alors bon cohn
bendit on l'a vu passer comme ça mais il
est toujours là vous en fais pas voulu
on le voit mois quand même hein c'est
une star une star ça bouge savez ça va
ça vient ça t'as vu comment quoi c'est
une star ses fans ça oui c'est une star
ben hammam star ça bouge à 20 ans dans
les livres d'histoire excusez moi
excusez du peu
via les voynettistes n'ose rien dire et
mammeri ça veut rien dire non plus il ya
le courant blandin pocrain face à un
sens et c'est que c'est pas un sens et
une guéguerre c'est une guerre de clans
dans le vert c'est ainsi que nous ayons
quelques attitudes ridicule parce que
nous sommes trop démocratique al interne
c'est possible maintenant ça n'a
strictement aucune importance
l'important c'est ce que nous arrivons à
changer au niveau externe donc dans la
société ce qu'on devra proposer qui
passe par exemple une des propositions
pour des trucs vous avez fait passer par
exemple depuis vous êtes associé que
jospin par bon super phénix vous l'avez
dit oui le trail à ce qui se passe grâce
à vous qu'est-ce que vous change
l'inversion des pistes cyclables à paris
c'est tiberi ce même pas vous la journée
sans voiture la journée sans voiture ses
idées avoue le salon écoute la panne
boom
je vous écoute la journée sans voiture
avec tous les gens qui conduisent leur
voiture par ils disent les gens n'y a
pas de voiture je prends la mienne ça va
rouler pas con donc la journée sans
voiture ça marche pas il est évident que
la journée soit ça ne marche pas c'était
les actes symboliques sont importants
aux politiques on se demande où vous en
être la taxe tobin par exemple qu'un
beau combat
ça avance ouais bon certains bus il a
dit que c'était pas possible je pas
entendu ça comme ça je pense
qu'effectivement ça se fait ça sera se
faire au niveau de l'union européenne
dans son ensemble six arrêts avoir à
l'intérêt une importance globale
exactement le bon exemple de réforme qui
n'est pas possible parce que c'est aux
mains d'autres personnes que les hommes
politiques
mais non l'adc la décision politique de
taxe tobin c'est les hommes politiques
qu'ils n'ont encore faut-il qu'ils la
mettent en place la dépénalisation du
cannabis
la légalisation la légalisation mais
bien évidemment dépénalisation ça veut
dire qu'on laisse le marché mathieu
continue et que la vente peut se faire
toujours avec des marchés mais feu
partout et qui a dans nos cités diverses
et variées de mafia divers et variés
dont sap vous êtes pour la vente du de
la marijuana dans les poneys pour une
vente contrôlés très terriblement
contrôler mais une vente mais bien sûr
c'est vrai c'est sûr ils ont deux
avantages quand même
c'est qu'on aura eu la bonne herbe est
tous avec les verts passent et la
tentation
ben si ces contrôles et vous m'avez oui
mais vous avez bien vu ce qui arrive sur
le marché des nourritures et tout ça
mais bon c'est là qu'au jour bon c'est
quoi ces vous acceptez les choses c'est
chez vous ça c'est vrai avant
d'accueillir mon invité suivant j'ai
remercié massimo gargia je vais rappeler
donc le titre de son livre jet set les
mémoires d'un playboy internationale
vous hésitez pas à dire
thiam ainsi mancha
bien
alors le personnage que nous allons
recevoir maintenant est venu il ya deux
ans dans cette émission au tout début de
l'émission
il est venu pour raconter qu'il n'avait
pas le droit de de publier sa biographie
d'un de long parce que le synopsis en
forme à en parler avait été donnée alain
delon aujourd'hui il a publié la
biographie d'alain delon la biographie
non autorisée l'un d'eux l'on voit si
bernard violet là messieurs
des sketches et par le look de violer la
jeune et belle idée comme ça
il a une cravate et tout mais quand il
sort dans le monde y met une cravate un
bernard j'essaie d'être propre
effectivement il essaye d'être propre et
où ses larmes il est pas secrétaire
nationale des verts il n'est pas
écrivain à succès il n'est pas star de
cinéma et tout donc mis une cravate
c'est quelque chose d'assez beau la vie
quand on est moins bien défini il va
l'enlever la cravate oil et lagrave à
voir mettez vous à l'aise
berlin voit là son idée mais voilà comme
ça vous là les six blessés n'a cassé la
tête je vais l'enlever car donc voilà
à l'aller on travaille on en donne hélas
sandrine a les mains au couvent où
l'entrée de cadeaux shoebiz la voix la
cendrillon a rapporté à vincent lindon
qui vient alors cette journaliste 11 ans
j'ai travaillé à france 3 tf1 puis après
être devenu écrivain reporter les
intéressés à pas mal de personnages
troubles à commencer par françois
mitterrand au pasteur doucé à carlos à
papon au bond qui est françois lamy de
mitterrand un maître vergès donc vous
aimez les personnages comme ça un petit
peu troublée qui berlin au boulot ou
bien ils qui s'appelle les mystères de
long donc chez flammarion
pourquoi delon pourquoi s'intéresser à
de longs non c'est tout bête c'est tout
simple pourquoi pas de longs jeudi c'est
aussi un des plus grands acteurs
français contre bab el menzeh moi parce
que personnage ambigu complexe bon qui
peut qui plus que jamais le moins de six
classiques à dire du guépard qu avant
tout les filles que nous connaissons et
que nous admirons c'est quand même là
des français les plus connus au monde
c'est aussi l'une des personnalités je
veux dire les plus populaires et voir
controversé aussi d'auray en france
alors en 98 vous avez vous écrit un
synopsis sur une biographie non
autorisée d'alain delon vous la donner
aux éditions grasset que notre ami
beigbeder connaît bien et donc laure
adler qu'elle n'est plus là à l'époque
laure adler travaillait chez grasset et
donc elle qu'est ce qu'elle fait elle
reçoit votre synopsis pour elle le donne
alain delon réussit une amie
effectivement une vraie reine jamais
travaillé dix auparavant chez plon et
qui effectivement s'est cru obligé de
donner en douce le synopsis à ce qu'elle
avait lu vraiment où est ce qu'elle a
voulu faire plaisir aux avocats de long
un bon tout partout de long qui lui
portent plainte et vous vous portez
plainte contre grasse et parce que
finalement ça se fait pas quoi wizo
tourner en rond là on a rangé take-two
secret ronald d
autre mais bon finalement je veux dire
que delon a réagi comme il réagit
habituellement j'ai pas le premier
biographe qu'il interdit d'écrire un
bouquin il avait déjà fait dans les
années 80 la disant que tout pataquès
qui a eu pour koné c'est moins la
démarche de l'eau qui était quelqu'un
c'est brutal a ses bons et mais de la
décision de justice et du comment ce
réaliste qui a dit bon voilà tel
écrivain ne peut pas écrire debout car
ça devrait vous intéresser savez c'est
assez curieux c'est que c'est un cas
unique dans l'iss procès de la dronne de
livres interdits avant même d'avoir été
écrit oui c'était une jour que le livre
est le dernier refuge de la liberté et
la même de même ça enfin vous avez des
problèmes avec les marques on en a parlé
mais même ça vous ça vous était
interdite puisque vous avez même pas pu
écrire le livre puisque déjà le synopsis
était interdit donc voilà quelques mois
oui en tout cas justice a débouté de
long de tout c'est alors allez vous
voulez donner votre projet aussi à
fayard alors fayard c'est pire que tout
ils ont demandé la permission à deux ans
également la réponse a été non non aux
échanges avaient déjà sorti trois
bouteilles chez fayard claude durand ta
grands patrons il a dit le projet
m'intéresse mais ce serait bien que de
l'on soit d'accord donc il a pris sa
pluie puisqu'il connaissait lui a écrit
un petit évidemment l'autre à dire en à
hockey mineur il n'a pas répondu du tout
voilà et vous l'avez proposé à
flammarion qui à l'époque a dit non et
aujourd'hui les résidents c'est parce
que de l'eau était intervenu
personnellement avait téléphoné au pdg
directrice générale en disant je suis au
courant qu approche des biographies vous
concernant vous l'a publié je vous fais
un procès vous le perdez bon
effectivement ça fait peur quand unique
effectivement les procès coûterait cher
mais flammarion a dit non d'un premier
temps et depuis quelques semaines un
état a dit on va pas se laisser
intimider
on va faire ce bouquin avec avec je lai
on veut signer
un contrat avec un faux nom s'était
appelé les hommes du président hu y
aller chercher de l'eau là dedans mais
ça s'est bien passé
alors donc le synopsis donné à deux ans
par laure adler a été publié à l'époque
par marianne 3,6 des numéros du 17 août
98 et donc on va voir on va comparer un
petit peu si vous voulez bien vert
violet ce qu'ils avaient dans le
synopsis escale en bouquin
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il
alors bernard violet donc on va comparer
un petit peu sur les origines de 2,2
l'on sait à peu près ce que vous aviez
prévu d'écrire donc le père de l'onf a
bien de long et gérant d'un cinéma à
bourg-la-reine qui s'appelle le regina
il quitte la mère edith qui épouse à ce
moment là le charcutier de la grande rue
de bourg la reine
paul boulogne jusque là c'est à peu près
ce que vous aviez prévu
alors là où ça commence à diverger entre
le synopsis et de livres c'est ça la
liberté d'expression
c'est au sujet de l'indochine dans le
synopsis vous écrivez que delon est
poursuivi pour vol d'une jeep ça assez
dans le bouquin mais vous dites qu'est
saigon il est l'amant d'un dénommé et
dont le livre vous écrivez qu'évidemment
il vole ou jeep via plus de trace de son
amant de saigon parce que ça relève de
la vie privée parce que je n'ai pas pu
avoir parce que nous réussirons assure
en fait je n'étais je n'ai pas pu
recouper j'ai recoupé effectivement
cette information mais j'ai pas pu la
publier je n'ai pas voulu publier parce
que ça relève de la vie privée des
internautes et où c'est vrai que c'est
vrai que delon a fasciné les femmes
durant de longues années et il fasciné
l'excité la même façon les hommes c'est
vrai c'est pas un secret bon il était
beau la batcave gauche de long était de
vote ont l'amour n'a rien avec ce bien
alors premier point bon ensuite de long
il rentre à marseille alors dans le
synopsis écrivait que alain delon est
arrêté pour avoir acheté un revolver un
trafiquant qu'il a des lancers et dans
les vous écrivez que mais un vol de
revolver dans des circonstances jamais
bien éclairci dans les deux cas il fait
45 jours de prison
là aussi vous êtes un petit peu en
retrait par rapport au synopsis vous
n'avez pas comparer un synopsis en bar
aria moi j'étais à travers des
complications avec un travail d' enquête
sérieux qui a duré effectivement 2
jour depuis deux ans où je là j'ai pu
recouper les informations où j'ai pu
recueillir des témoignages recueillis
dans des documents requestionner de long
at il attaqué va-t-il attaquer est ce
que ce livre peut être saisi en référé
ou pas ça la vraie question parce que
s'il le fait sur un synopsis il va le
faire sur votre livre pour l'instant
depuis une semaine que le livre sorti
naples est sorti en se livrant même
temps 1 à dire qu'on ne souhaite pas
référé il mord livre est sorti en douce
sont la chair hasard en catimini par eau
douce folie continue alors dans le
synopsis écrivait que romy schneider
partage alain delon avec visconti dans
synopsis dans le livre vous écrivez
visconti est impressionné par la beauté
du jeune homme et que remis dément les
relations amoureuses de long avec
wisconsin tout à fait exact c'est pas un
secret
visconti aimer les hommes il a est
amoureux d'alain delon il est amoureux
du photographe or celle qui a vécu
pendant pas mal d'années et beaucoup de
de cocteau est amoureux de sa mère je
vous dis là bernard bon je dis ça
donnait accès écrivait que romy
schneider doit partager deux longs avec
visconti est dans les normes et autre
chose écrivait que vit ce qu'on avait
impressionné par la beauté du jeune
homme mais qui a l'air d'aimer les
relations qu un synopsis est un document
de travail destiné à une amie bon contre
les livres s'appelait secret d'alcôve
donc là je mettais à peu lâché dans ce
synopsis pensant lui faire plaisir je l'
ai rajouté quelques louches bon voilà
c'est tout sachant que c'est qu'on peut
dire des choses
en privé on peut dire des choses dans
les couloirs de votre studio 1 ils ont
dit les choses
un des histoires de fesses et du confort
y est
qu'est ce que j'avance qu'est ce que
j'avance à l'italienne sur votre plateau
bon ben on s'ajustera missionnaire
évoque effectivement donc la fascination
quand il ya ces mémoires comme un non
mais c'est comment vous avez su que romy
schneider évoqué telle ou telle chaîne
écrit jean crinon quoi dans son journal
qui est publié chez michel lafon je
crois et or il existe en fait vous
inventez pas grand chose alors il faut
lire le journal de romy schneider et
puis en fait c'est toujours vous avez
raison vous à ses côtés de la vie
personnelle d'alain delon on apprend à
grand chose
j'ai pris le
mesut oezil apprendre des choses qui te
quitte à se lancer sur quelques
intentions
alors qu'il travaille durant cette
session gibert la même qualité sont pas
les histoires de fesses qui vous
intéressent en revanche a beaucoup qui
est pour qu'on dévoile la vie privée des
stars ensemble et maintenant c'est et
c'est vous qui la protéger c'est le
monde à l'envers
c'est curieux je suis continuer parce
qu'il ya d'autres exemples par exemple
dans le synopsis écrivait qu alain delon
et l'amant de romy schneider facilité
dans le synopsis publié par marianne est
qu'alain delon et l'amant de romy
schneider plus de magna de magda pardon
schneider +2 georges boom qui était son
agent
1 et le soir quand il rentrait alain
quand il rentrait dans l'appartement de
georges boom il est bizarre parce que
l'attendent lui quand il rentrait remis
magda sa mère et georges baume chacun
espérant la voir pour lui pour la nuit
ça c'était dans le synopsis vie privée
vip et dans le livre vous écrivez
en fait la rencontre de alain delon et
georges beau mais vous dites il ya été
c'était un choc pour georges baume la
beauté éblouissante d'alain tout habillé
de cuir noir etc ont remis qui est logé
chez genre je vous en mets ça de poser
il va arriver à paris vous vous dites
que vous utilisez beaucoup la question
vous êtes très mal un bolide prévient-il
la naïve romy des ragots qui risque de
courir
que signifie cette étrange trio
entendons bien entente on bientôt dans
certaines rédactions 6 hiromi heures
pour reprendre les sources de leurs amis
schneider effectivement elle se pose
également toutes ces questions elle y
répond dans son journal
parce que effectivement c'est qu'on se
poser la question à l'époque elle a cru
bon il répondait lui raison je crois on
n'a pas là
il fait un synopsis garde et je me fais
jeter à la gale est maintenant il
revient avec un bouquin il nous dit bon
effectivement vous savez thierry vous
chercher la petite bête
lorsque vous faites très bien c'est la
technique de la question c'est ce que je
disais que signifie cette étrange trio
il ya un point d'interrogation donc ya
pas d'affirmations vous en sortez très
très bien bien alors sur la sphère marre
que vick en revanche là vous êtes
raccord avec le synopsis je dois vous le
dire
c'est à dire que 1 êtes gentil c'est le
chantage en tiges et les bons c'était
des clins d'oeil si j'ose dire à leurs
adler qui n'est pas fait pas destiné à
être publié
synopsis ne jamais sachant qu
effectivement ça s'était extrait aussi
d'un contexte avait 18 pages et synopsis
l'immensité ces lignes je veux dire tout
ça c'est ceci est intégré dans red
herring vous allez faire vendre beaucoup
d'exemplaires du marianne du 17 août
ils ont tout vendu à la ferme argovie
que la bombe l'utc en relation avec le
synopsis les relations de long avec le
milieu vous maintenez que marco vic
qu'elle est donc un truand yougoslave
était l'amant de nathalie delon qui
était une des femmes d'un geste est
connue la thalie laver la vaisselle
hiromi sur le procès verbal
et puis
jeudi elle avait dit d'ailleurs à sous
vous marrez pas là parce qu'il fait là
il prépare un livre sur vincent lindon
et
justement je répète je suis chamisa j'ai
sollicité d'ailleurs vincent lindon par
foyer et qui était le seul comédien qui
ne m'a pas répondu
marco bernard amende de nathalie delon
retrouvé mort bon ça vous est raccord
avec le synopsis il avait dit auparavant
mais qui touche à ma femme il est mort
je n'ai pas compris le mec qui touche à
ma femme il est mort il avait dit de
l'anc est ce que le temps va jetons plus
jolie xor il en est de la ville
celui qui me vole je pardonne celui qui
vole ma femme je loue tu apprends
l'herbe yougoslave pas par rapport à la
faire attention sachant de classe je ne
savais plus si c'était nathalie mireille
ou quelles femmes qui sont attendus que
l'on semblait d'ailleurs très portrait
alain delon c'est très étonnant
glasser des frères et soeurs j'étais un
grand homme nous avait il avait dérivé
des chemises ancrée de bancarel pareil
on a eu envie telle autre même lorsque
nathalie l'on fait lorsqu'on faisait des
bonds s'est déversée tatami donc
acquitté à la dire
de loi énormément souffert et je pense
que cela ait été sincère bien alors yens
chapitre de l'amitié d'alain delon avec
le pen ça ça n'a pas changé non plus les
enfants ça y'a pas de changement non
plus vg tout et j'ai vu les enfants il
les problèmes avec anthony les problèmes
relation père fille et l'attaqué au
tribunal quand il avait lancé une marque
de fringues qui s'appelait à d anthony
delon ça ressemblait alain delon donc il
attaquait son propre fils elle lui a au
tribunal
ça les fait néanmoins de mal chez jean
pierre foucault celles ci sont
réconciliés ils se sont réconciliés
alors il ya un outil dont vous parlez
qui est harry enfin rhône diaries qui
est le fils de la chanteuse under grande
nico qu'ait jamais été reconnue par de
longues et élevés par la mère de long un
jour de l'on appelle sa propre mère est
dit en lisant faut choisir maintenant si
tu continues à élever mon fils on se
parle plus assez pour que sa mère vient
dire à élever le fait c'est l'adopter le
donner son nom ouais c'est pas rien
ouais et là je crois que les problèmes
avec la mer ouais moi avec de longs
ouais bah oui je dirige sa mère cccc
mêler de sa vie privée
dire qu'il reconnaît ce qui ne laisse
pas de gamins ça la regarde et pas un de
s'impliquer dans les produits de soins
de la la j'ai récupéré ses fils et non
seulement le récupérer il rappelé du dé
son nom bref c'est un peu surréaliste
bibliothèque avec des chants guerriers
sur l'autre pleure quand on voit le film
effectivement allemande est très très
beau fils nicolas on voit harry qu'il y
ait subi ma rue semblant se rapporter
tout bouffer bon j'dis avait donné
raison à de loin je dirais oui
maintenant il a un peu dans la dèche non
c'est terrible moi lorsque j'ai
rencontré dans le navet 99 figé dans un
squat de listes du ve arrondissement
bon c'est pas c'est un secret de dire
que je la mettais des jeunes explique t
elle à passer partie d'après midi
ensemble et en partant il m'a demandé
d'un franc pour rentrer chez lui quoi
pour se payer mais trop petit clic bien
et puis alors il répond par avance parce
qu'il sait tout c'est alain delon donc
il répond dans le journal de karl zéro
qui s'appelle le vrai journal donc vous
l'avez lu ça je suis au courant puisque
un 15-0 devait publier les bonnes
feuilles du livre et puis qui s'est
dégonflé parce qu'il a eu peur de deux
longs skis se connaissent ils ont tourné
ensemble dans le film de toronto avec de
longues cartes 0 j'ai des amis d'alain
delon car il n'y a pas trahi et ma
patrie il a pas non c'est là sur ces
deux bouquins ouais donc mais il voulait
remettre dans le court terme ou alain
delon reinsdorf et voilà je dis à nos
amis téléspectateurs merci beaucoup vers
l'inde et l'afrique
à
voilà non mais c'est étonnant ce qu'on
appelait dans cette émission
bonjour j'espère qu'elle a été regardé
cette émission on avait vraiment un
dehors du fait qu'on était là mais je
veux dire avec bdc las vegas vous
connaissez twitter
oui j'y ai cru reconnaissez c'est un mec
qui me fait rire c'est idiot
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
titoff non monsieur
m
[Musique]
il
le titan
mais non
qu'il paraît
non
qui va
l'histoire mais moi c'est tranquille
maintenant voter titeuf en vérité bien
titoff vous exprès titoff les petites
mains bernard violet les petites mains
comment elles font les petites mains
elles font comment les petites mains
bien alors donc reprise du spectacle au
palais des glaces 37 faubourg du temps
je le dis parce qu'on est tous comme ça
a été les faubourgs eu un match à 37
faubourg du temple
ça va tu as très bien 31 décembre 2000
jusqu'au 31 décembre 2008 a fait du
boulot quand même à saab et oui
justement j'avais chaque fois on parle
de ça et je suis un glandeur et que ça
chauffe ou rien mais coup je me suis
fait avoir
moi j'ai choisi ça je ne suis je vais
être peinard arrêté en fait on bosse et
6ème journée commence et s'il y avait
que ça sert que sur m6music tous les
jours à 17h vous faites une émission qui
s'appelle vos clips et vous tournez
direct il tourne dans l'adaptation et
baise moi maintenant ils sont en train
d'adapter des jolies choses je leur
demande virginie despentes
c'est gilles paquet brenner qui fait ça
hein et alors vous jouez avec patrick
bruel stomy bugzy marion cotillard fait
quoi comme rôle moi je fais le rôle de
sébastien qui est
qui est qui sort de prison qui est le
fiancé d'une des deux jumelles et je
peux pas en dire plus parce que ouais
après je vais un peu [ __ ] le film vous
aviez déjà joué dans comme un aimant le
film de d'akhenaton avec la musique de
bellezane blackburn
c'était bien ce gars bien alors sur
scène on dit vous êtes le roi des
glandeurs mais en fait tu voulais pas du
tout le royaume c'est vrai que c'est
beau comme un malade
moi j'ai vu votre spectacle ça m'a
plutôt fait marrer je voulais dit
d'ailleurs fait bien rire
bon ben on va regarder ce que tu fais
sur scène c'est plus à wes madiko
[Musique]
par contre comme j'aimais pas trop con
dios ce que je faisais ce que je prenais
tout le monde un stop dès que je voyais
quelqu'un faire du sport je prenais bon
des fois j'étais un peu précieux en ce
que je faisais j'arrivais avec la
voiture comme ça je m'en arrêter comme
ça et quand ses rivaux au niveau de la
voiture ça je redémarre et sur le coup
je leur faisais gagné 3,04 100 m l'autre
jour j'étais chez moi où la tranquille
en plein après midi comme ça chez chez
moi notre âne qui joue je me disais le
coup et n'apporta mondes douanes ont
jeté billet vous haïr pleinement un peu
après midi comme ça des coups je reçois
une lettre commence en plein après midi
mais quel que soit le monde devient fou
on est calme toi qui te ferait remonter
en fin d'après midi et en fait c'était
c'est une invitation pour une soirée
mondaine à chaque fois ça va être bien
vrai bon moi je savais pas trop comment
m'habiller
alors ce que j'ai fait j'ai téléphoné
une copine à moi qui ai un peu
l'habitude d'être tout de suite elle m'a
dit ah oui tu vas une soirée moindre la
grande mode en ce moment des semis dieu
sait mettre des baskets avec un constat
merci beaucoup à manger chercher de plus
après midi comme un fou des costards des
costards bon j'ai pas trouvé de costa
lorsque j'ai fait moi je la surveille
avec mon cas c'est un gros soyez des
chiffres comme ça je me met dans la
bouche comme ça je vois je vois en cours
comme le temps
ça pique ça fait comme des bonbons
godard était petit c'est pas bon mais
c'est bon mais on respecte plus là c'est
la nature mais le monde devient fou quoi
alors alors dans 50 millions d'années ya
plus de couche d'ozone et personne ne
dit rien le subit et je sais pas si vous
avez remarqué
si tu fixé pendant très très longtemps
une étoile ça avec les fenêtres ouvertes
mais déjà c'est une soleil la fidh
pendant très très longtemps que ça fait
très longtemps que ça dès la fixant à
bout de bons mots au bout d'un moment tu
y crois moi j'ai un truc surtout
pourront jamais être stressé j'ai une
règle d'or c'est ne jamais remettre les
chansons donnent d'eux mais juste
d'annuler carrément ça marche ça marche
le spectacle ouais ouais on est super
content ouais mais c'est à dire qu'aux
autres et visant à prolonger jusqu'à
jusqu'à mi juillet on avait envie de
continuer hélas la demande de chirag les
verts aussi demande et ont donc j'ai
attaqué là depuis une semaine au palais
des glaces et on est super contents ça
se passe bien
alors donc si vous n'avez spectacle de
titoff
il va vous convaincre d'aller le voir et
il a trois minutes pour convaincre
lumière c'est dur on peut faire un petit
coup de huy
merci alors pourquoi il faut les bons
spectacles alors c'est surtout il faut
voir mon spectacle je n'ai pas passé par
quatre chemins et je vais pas raconter
n'importe quoi je veux pas non plus trop
raconté le spectacle c'est pas le but du
jeu je pense mais bon déjà je me change
bien 850 fois dans le spectacle je
change de visage comme ça l'homme au
milieu milliers de visages c'est moi
c'est pas braquer tease c'est ça
nécessite en fait c'est moi
il ya beaucoup de liens des feux
d'artifice et quand ça beaucoup d'effets
spéciaux de technique alain delon passe
aussi derrière quand ça passe à poil
alain delon à toi la novia l'indolent à
poil dans mon spectacle ça tu pourras le
rajouter au style autre temps fou à
l'est le long et parfois le cas des
ennuis
mais pas à ses filles dans les statuts
il ya des chevaux dans le spectacle est
un sinon sinon il ya aussi beaucoup
d'effets spéciaux je vais répéter il ya
aussi il ya aussi des j'ai pris un gros
cap man comme c'est un show à
l'américaine gf104 management c'est ce
que ses avocats demandent c'est un mec
normal sauf qu'il a deux roquettes dans
le dos et des réacteurs propulseur
nucléaire voit ça c'est pas très
écologique et où il part comme ça alors
ils arrivent ils à nouveau de robots
d'artifice et moi au début ce que je
faisais ça c'était au trévise je
raccroche et derrière lui on partait
comme ça que deux fusées j'ai
complètement arrêté sinon il ya aussi il
ya des les gens viennent les gens j'ai
été aussi surpris les gens naturellement
ils viennent avec des bandes jour 1
viennent avec alors quand banjo il joue
du banjo comme ça pendant ils ont des
pétales de roses dans sa djette des
pétales de roses certains font l'amour
alors c'est normal c'est seraient les
nouveaux spectacles comiques et on met
un peu de poppers dans la machine
je suis retourné à paris non mais voilà
c'était un spectacle tout simple quand
on l'a fait on a essayé de faire simple
et des temps en temps il ya des petits
des petits gags comme ça si le coussin
péteur ah oui voilà donc voyager même
bien ben oui il reste encore comme il me
reste là aussi on demandait pourquoi on
dit quand j'achète un comité des fois
l'impression que tu t'engages pas ouais
ça engage pas socialement pourquoi tu
fais pas passer des messages au niveau
social comme ça et là et là moi je dis
je c'est faux parce que je me demande
comme dernièrement que je trouve que le
monde devient complètement fou
je suis d'accord un petit peu avec ce
que disait mon ami fred ça fait trois
minutes merci
lacroix
et
il allait dire un truc super important
sinon comme un temps geronimo des
messages lumière la lumière tant gérant
luigi 50 secondes de plus la dernière
voilà ça va être ça va être le moment
d'émotion il ya un grand moment
d'émotion dans le spectacle peut dire
que moi je moi aussi je voudrais faire
passer un message je pense que le
message on va on va y arriver tous
ensemble on va on va y arriver à être
peinard tranquille à vivre bien sans
pollution
vous allez lire des bons petits bouquins
comme ça et surtout la loi des 35 heures
je pense que c'est qu'un début on va
arriver bien à deux trois heures de
travail par jour qu'on va y arriver
grâce à internet car ce afin de changer
parce que tous ensemble on va y arriver
on va être bien peinard merci
[Applaudissements]
c'est bien alors un titeuf c'est bon
c'est pas votre vrai nom
si si titoff moi je m'appelle christophe
avezac à christophe jeune k way de plan
de cuques
c'est une sorte de ça et comme
christophe santelli sodome quelle que
soit la surface et non seulement ça
titov c'est pour dire qu'on va faire
l'interview pseudo on ne bouge pas
pendant mes singles
[Musique]
l'interview pseudo c'est pas compliqué
il faut trouver les vrais noms des gens
que je vais citer si la carte 0 bravo
non mais quel est le vrai nom d'anne
rico macias j'ai le couscous nom david
merguez non on trouve recherches
commencent à enrico macias son vin non
non non et dacia guenassia bravo et
qu'elle a c'est assez chaud c'est gaston
ghrenassia
et le vrai nom de lio s'est mis au piano
le vrai nom de johnny hallyday vrai nom
de pascal obispo
le renault mégane et lara lor web à
savoir la mode et pas très nouveau dvd
je savais que ça mais il ya un truc plus
facile c'est le vrai nom de julien clerc
leclerc bravo paula leclair le vrai nom
de madonna bravo le maître de chai la
sheila ceringo non vous paraissez non
elle s'appelle anne guérette est
inscrite au nom quelque chose oui ami à
lui après 2016 bonjour les way m
quel est le vrai nom de michel drucker
c'est le prépuce
non le vrai nom de michel drucker sont
vraiment c'était inquiète le vrai nom de
serge gainsbourg dans gainsbourg
car avant l'univers du seigneur le vrai
nom de patrick sébastien le petit
bonhomme en mousse
les baby sébastien s'appelle ces drames
ont choqué qu'on qu'une chaude à nu ce
nom qui a dit ça voilà bravo mairie si
tu as un bon vous dites c'est son
physique bouton patrick boutora et son
fils appelé sébastien dirait bien le
vrai nom attention cas de sandrine le
vrai nom de sophie marceau à l'intérieur
de la serre linkin berlin c'est quoi
swing du bernois
attention vous êtes concentré le vrai
nom de zazie de tricher de l'aref besoin
isabelle de truchis de varennes truchis
de varennes le vrai nom d'eddy mitchell
non non pas au seul essai par ferrat
aimer
mais je suis pas tout seul samaras avait
des échanges et une qui berne
aidez-vous très bien très très bien
j'étais trois gagnants je pas fait le
compte catherine mais voici jubilé de
connaître tous
alors maintenant on va faire le blind
test l'épreuve finale de cette émission
vous savez que depuis trois semaines une
star est née
cette star s'appelle michael il a battu
tout le monde au blind test jusqu'à
maintenant et ce soir il revient
[Musique]
allez
carla
je reste
michael est une star des blind test vous
êtes fort fait avec les bd au blind test
ouais j'avais linda hardy elle file elie
répondent chaque année au lycée
j'aime les gens là de nous a donné les
réponses écologie en juillet 3
bon alors donc c'est un blind test
spécial nuit en l'honneur de mon ami
frédéric beigbeder qui a beaucoup
pratiqué la nuit avant de devenir
philosophes modernes chiant d'ailleurs
oui vous parlez moins de gang bang canal
depuis vous êtes numéro un des ventes
michael tu feras ghost alger en verre
qui tapissaient dessus puis
déstabilisation d'adversaires états unis
nation notre version non non ça ne
servira à rien
attention frédéric vous êtes concentré
spéciale nuit nuit oui c'était ennuyant
le maire de frédérike bennahmias et à
l'abri de jouer à nice
j'essaye critique où il ya de lactation
wen dans les titille à lui ou night
effet l'artiste nom du chanteur et ça
ira très bien s'en charger le mais le
mec est remarquablement doué et un micro
et la micro il a décroché les micros
cravates haut et fort ce que nous
entendons bien didier premières chansons
qu'est ce
après
zéro point noté des points en régie
parce que là franchement je crois que ce
soir ça va être excellent pourquoi
est-ce que je peux avoir la deuxième
chanson s'il vous plaît
15h08 ya déjà des donneurs il indiqué
c'est olivier qui l'annoncé lors il a le
poids il a dit qu à reconnecter avec lui
ou quoi
maintenant c'est bien j'ai ouvert c'est
pas compliqué serge un petit replay pour
sa lecture on peut faire un petit replay
passé à paris qui a répondu contrôle
vidéo contrôle vidéo il dit l'été 2010
il a dit la bible dans sa cellule
je suis désolé dans une motion
j'enchaîne effectivement jansem avec la
troisième chanson d'idées
[Musique]
non non c'est bien fait des décalages
vous ne me regardez pas vous regarder
que le géant vert là j'ai dit let's
paint the night together et de
l'agrément fargo alors écoutez il
faudrait de professionnels avoir un
huissier de justice ici qu'ils
contrôlent parce que si on fait les
choses avaient fait une saison réussie
que kd a répondu à l'ats pierre bonté la
base il
non mais les contrôles en bas à yaya
suite satané moineau chanson numéro 15
attention
je sais
manuella maury qui
les élus noël made in bangkok
[Musique]
bravo
j one night in bangkok mauvaise série
call encore maintenant je suis désolé
moi je peux pas avoir les yeux partout
j'ai des juges de touche qui sont
dispersés dans la salle et qui utilise
qui a répondu c'est évidemment me réel
ou and lighting banque en floride état
fort et d'apport non mérité sa victoire
sauf qu'on n'arrive plus à s'en
débarrasser maintenant bien chanson
numéro 5 4
à
énorme et ça avec un jukebox mais qu'est
ce que je peux si le mec trouve facile
non mais qu'est-ce que j'y peux chez que
c'est vexant pour vous je le connais
vous habitez secrétaire générale des
verts porte-parole numéro un des ventes
de livres en france
meilleur jeune comique meilleur ami
d'alain delon sandrine kiberlain
meilleure actrice de sa génération je
suis désolé vous faites tous battre
parce que j y ai qu est ce qu on fait
pareil aujourd'hui la panne ayant
simplement venir de nuit dans un hôtel
comme les oreilles comme jean pierre
léaud comme jean pierre léaud dans les
films de truffaut veilleur de nuit dans
un hôtel chanson numéro 6 apporte quoi
je connaissais
d'aller dans la presse en parle
c'est le début et a pris la révélation
yanfolila de folie
liane foly à coeur
j'avais des fiches n'était pas là
m
chanson numéro 7 est banni
les années ont passé
des lunettes truqués tu regardes tu
haïras ton frère jumeau à ton frère
jumeau celui-la as tu lui dis des trucs
avec ta bouche soit ta langue qu'ils
parlent à bas tarifs d'enseignés ça ne
sera pas arrivé à se lancer les avions
didier remet nous les avions du qui se
souvient des avions j'en sais rien la
révélation des athées
[Musique]
chang mai
deux solutions ou vous voyez ma femme
qui prépare ses blind test en dehors de
moi ou alors vous êtes très fort voilà
alors là frédéric si vous trouvez pas
celle-là je vous en voudrez pas virer
vraiment mes chances en numéro 8
[Musique]
à
mais mais mais
non vous vous commencez en dix ans les
trucks et les trucks et week-end la soul
et rock
hélas ces all day all night les kings
ont suivi quatre mois par mozart série
legacy musique classique
je suis anéantie c'est l'importance
qu'elle a gagnée puisqu'il a déjà trouvé
4 attend une hideuse doublement qu on va
faire le super-banco mais d'abord c'est
pour bernard violet vous allez me dire
qu'ils chantent bernard c'est étrange
mallet
voilà dans le terrain de l'ombre à vos
amis bref avec dieu les organes à
bonchamp son numéro 9
c'est par ses colocataires
c'est
ce site offre vous ne saviez vous le
saviez sandrine kiberlain
bah ouais c'est un minou la révélation
didier cette petite up léger c'est paul
mccartney avec ses fameux wings et oui
bien sûr didier la révélation
c'est
cancer
carlyle bravo titoff
[Musique]
maintenant mesdames et messieurs le
super banco
alors là c'est très très dur parce que
la chanson a été interprétée il ya une
version originale par un groupe et une
reprise quelques années plus tard par
une star mondiale
[Musique]
guilbaud les rôlistes ans par morrison
cent jours
mais dense
même passé pas messieurs vous avez dit
warren pour moi
m
et oui hier comme de nay et qui par peur
et chantée par lev et maintenant
frédéric pour prouver votre génie absolu
vous allez nous dire qui interprète la
chanson qui vient didier
[Musique]
arrêtez tout pour garder
on avait beau
oui bah ouais bon
le thème marc david bowie sur l'album
une hotte à nous tout cela oui
michael était de retour à l'écart
à tora le nickel pour la photo et
michael sera là la semaine prochaine est
ce qu'on peut faire la petite photo s'il
vous plaît monsieur kalfon voila voila
merci pour la semaine prochaine mais
j'aime ça n'arrive pas avec son humeur
avec son micro mains de ski c'est que la
semaine prochaine il aura besoin de ce
mythe romain à il est là il va être là
jusqu'à la fin de l'année je ne vois pas
comment on pourra le déloger va
remplacer pivot s'est lui donné on se
demandait qui allait remplacer pirlo
s'est peut-être michael effectivement
voilà c'est donc tout le monde en parle
massimo gargia jet set chez michel lafon
un livre meilleur qu'il en a l'air
l'allemand revient usb les 99 ans en
tête des ventes chez grasset beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de talent titoff au
palais des glaces jusqu'au 30 décembre
2004 et oh la grosse émission sur
comédie tous les jours à 19h jean luc
bennahmias ba a voté pour lui insufflant
de rougir bernard violet les mystères de
long chez flammarion
sandrine kiberlain tout va bien on sent
ce clown maury est avec nous michel
piccoli natacha régnier voilà au revoir
et à la semaine prochaine
pour vous
[Musique]
à
non
[Musique]
jamais
m
idem
baby
jusqu'où
et qui est
l'escargot
tu t'es mieux
m
[Musique]
nous venons
on
non
[Musique]
l'eau